OK, Sarah. So it's ten to 1:00 on a Friday night in November, and we're sitting on your porch. And it seems pretty quiet.
好的，莎拉。现在是11月一个周五的晚上，快凌晨1点钟了，我们坐在你家的门廊上。看起来挺安静的。
It's not that bad.
其实没那么糟。
One of the producers of our radio show, Sarah Koenig, moved to a college town because her husband got a job teaching there. And by day, her neighborhood is like a college town that you would see in an old Hollywood film. Beautiful professors' homes built in the '20s and '30s. Tree-lined streets. Gardens.
我们广播节目的制片人之一，莎拉·凯尼格，搬到了一个大学城，因为她丈夫在那里得到了一份教职。白天，她所在的街区就像你在好莱坞老电影里看到的大学城一样。建于20世纪20和30年代漂亮的教授住宅，绿树成荫的街道，还有花园。
But by night, we'd been on her porch for five minutes when--
但到了晚上，我们在她门廊才坐了五分钟，就——
They seem drunk. These kids seem drunk. This couple here, they're sort of staggering a bit. I think he's like holding her up or something.
他们看起来喝醉了。这些孩子看起来喝醉了。这儿有对情侣，他们走路有点踉踉跄跄的。我觉得男的在扶着女的，或者别的什么。
It's nine students walking down the middle of the street. Happens all the time.
那是九个学生走在街道中间。这种事经常发生。
It's noisy, right? It's like it doesn't occur to them at all, I think, that there are people just in these houses trying to sleep. And I kind of remember being that way in college, too, actually.
很吵，对吧？我想他们根本就没意识到，这些房子里还有人正试图睡觉。其实，我记得我在上大学时也这样。
Yeah, I do too.
是的，我也是。
Six minutes later, there's another group of drunk students. One tosses something onto a lawn.
六分钟后，又是另一群喝醉的学生。其中一个往草坪上扔了什么东西。
Can you guys pick up your trash, please? Can you pick up your plate, your pizza plate, please? People live here.
嘿，你们能把垃圾捡起来吗？能把那个盘子，那个披萨盘捡起来吗？有人住在这儿。
They pay no attention.
他们根本不理会。
Five minutes after that, we hear this clattering from the alley that runs next to Sarah's house.
五分钟后，我们听到莎拉家旁边的巷子里传来一阵叮当声。
Whoa, what was that? Actually, I'd kind of like to know what that was.
哇，那是什么？其实，我还真想知道那是什么。
What's going on?
怎么回事？
We run down the alley. Two college boys run away as they see us coming. Don't go back there, you could get raped, they yell to Sarah.
我们跑进巷子。两个大学生看到我们过来就跑了。别去那儿，会被强奸的，他们对莎拉喊道。
See, OK. They get threw somebody's trashcan, or like drop kicked it up in the air.
看吧，好吧。他们把别人的垃圾桶撞翻了，或者说是踢飞到了空中。
12 minutes after that, from the other direction, we hear a scraping and a loud rumbling, I guess.
12分钟后，从另一个方向，我们听到一阵摩擦声和巨大的轰鸣声，我想是这样。
That's somebody's property. That might have been a sign, actually.
那是别人的财产。那可能是一个标志牌，真的。
I don't know how many street signs you need to hear dragged through your neighborhood before you can recognize the sound it makes from all the way around the corner, but apparently my colleague Sarah has seen whatever that number is. We go to investigate and find two guys.
我不知道在你能从拐角处辨认出街道标志被拖行时发出的声音之前，需要听到多少个标志牌被拖行，但显然我的同事莎拉已经见识过了那个数字是多少。我们去调查，发现有两个家伙。
So just describe what you've got here.
描述一下你们这儿有什么。
A stop sign.
一个停车标志。
Nice big pole on it.
上面还有根又大又漂亮的柱子。
A stop sign. That's kind of a big thing when you see it up close, isn't it?
一个停车标志。近看这玩意儿挺大个的，不是吗？
Sorry.
抱歉。
Where did you find that? Like, where does it belong?
你们从哪儿发现它的？它本该在哪儿？
I don't know.
我不知道。
That is a good question.
问得好。
We just found it on a lawn. We found it on a lawn.
我们刚在草坪上发现的。我们是在草坪上找到的。
Oh, you found it on someone's lawn.
噢，你们在别人的草坪上发现的。
It was already ripped off.
它本来就被扯下来了。
Yeah, it was already [BLEEP].
是啊，它本来就[消音]了。
We just decided, hey, why not make use of it and take it?
我们只是觉得，嘿，为什么不利用一下把它带走呢？
Of course, this story makes no sense at all. I inform the two guys that I don't need to know their names.
当然，这故事完全讲不通。我告诉那两个家伙，我不需要知道他们的名字。
Well, in that case, we took it from the corner right there.
好吧，既然这样，我们是从那边的拐角处拿的。
Which one?
哪一个？
Where that car just turned. Pretty sure.
刚才那辆车转弯的地方。我很确定。
Pulled it out of the ground?
从地里拔出来的？
Yeah, it was cemented in pretty well. Just get a little rocking back and forth between two people, comes right up.
对，它水泥封得很牢。两个人来回晃几下，就出来了。
Did you guys come from like a house party somewhere?
你们是从哪里的家庭派对过来的吗？
No. We were just hanging out with a bunch of friends, just drinking. Taking some shots.
不，我们只是和一群朋友待在一起，喝酒，喝了几杯。
Seems like kind of an academic distinction to me, but.
对我来说这似乎是一个学术上的区别，但是。
With that, the other guy starts running with the street sign toward Garner Street, which is hard, because it's attached to a seven foot metal pole, and it's heavy. Sarah and I go back around the corner to her front yard. The evening is not over at all. Just in time to spot another student, this one coming out of a garden. Sarah assumes from the bushes back there.
说完，另一个人开始扛着路标朝加纳街跑去，这很困难，因为它连着一根七英尺高的金属杆，而且很重。莎拉和我转回拐角处，回到她的前院。夜晚根本还没结束。刚好撞见另一个学生，这家伙正从花园里出来。莎拉推测他是从后面的灌木丛里出来的。
I didn't pee.
我没撒尿。
Really? Really?
真的吗？真的？
I was just sitting down.
我只是坐下来而已。
He goes. And it's not a minute later that Sara points toward the alley, where there are three girls in miniskirts, under a streetlight, fully visible.
他走了。没过一分钟，莎拉指向巷子，那里有三个穿着迷你裙的女孩，在路灯下，清晰可见。
Peeing, peeing, peeing, peeing, peeing. [INAUDIBLE]
撒尿，撒尿，撒尿，撒尿，撒尿。[听不清]
One girl hikes up her skirt.
一个女孩提起裙子。
Get back, get back, get back.
退后，退后，退后。
But they're peeing in my yard. They're peeing in my yard. That's my car, OK, and three feet back is a girl's white ass, peeing.
可她们在我的院子里撒尿。她们在我的院子里撒尿。那是我的车，好吗，三英尺外就是一个女孩的白屁股，在撒尿。
She saw we saw her. She stopped. She stopped.
她看到我们看见她了。她停下了。她停下了。
You know, that might be why the plants grow really, really well in that spot, I'm just realizing.
你知道，我刚意识到，这可能就是为什么那个地方的植物长得特别特别好的原因。
Sarah's caught other groups of girls peeing in that same spot. Once she heard a girl say, "This is a good place. I go here all the time."
莎拉抓到过其他群体在同一个地方撒尿。有一次她听到一个女孩说：“这地方不错。我常来这儿。”
They're so embarrassed. There's like, muffled giggling happening across the street.
她们好尴尬。街对面传来闷闷的吃吃笑声。
The college town that Sarah lives in is State College, Pennsylvania, home of Penn State University, which this year was named the number one party school in the country by the people who name the number one party school, the Princeton Review. And this is apparently what it means to be the number one party school. From the moment that Sarah and I turned on the tape recorder to the moment that she sent those girls looking for somebody else's yard to pee in, it's only been 34 minutes. It's 1:30 in the morning.
莎拉居住的大学城是宾夕法尼亚州的州立学院，宾夕法尼亚州立大学所在地。今年，它被评选为全国第一派对学校，评选机构是普林斯顿评论。显然，这就是成为第一派对学校的含义。从莎拉和我按下录音机的那一刻起，到她把那些女孩赶去别人的院子撒尿，才过了34分钟。现在是凌晨1点半。
The fact that we saw that much mayhem sort of going on, at one corner-- so that means it's, multiply that by, you know, this entire neighborhood and other neighborhoods around-- people are peeing everywhere, garbage cans are getting kicked, stop signs are getting pulled out of the road, people are littering. You know.
我们亲眼目睹了这么多混乱在发生，在一个拐角——这意味着乘以整个街区，以及周围的其他街区——到处都有人在撒尿，垃圾桶被踢，停车标志被拔出路面，人们到处乱扔垃圾。你知道的。
The Princeton Review chooses the number one party school from online student surveys. 120,000 students at 371 schools around the country answered these questions. "How widely used are beer, alcohol, marijuana, and other drugs at your school?" "How big is frat life at your school?" And finally, "How many hours do you study each day?"
普林斯顿评论是通过在线学生调查选出第一派对学校的。全国371所学校的12万名学生回答了这些问题。“你们学校啤酒、酒精、大麻和其他毒品的使用有多广泛？”“你们学校的兄弟会生活有多盛大？”最后，“你们每天学习多少小时？”
Students aren't randomly selected, so it's not, strictly speaking, a scientific survey. But the last two years, Penn State has done very well. It was the number three party school last year, number six the year before that, and nobody argues it is not a very big school for partying.
学生不是随机抽选的，所以严格来说，这不是一项科学调查。但过去两年，宾州立大学表现非常好。去年是第三派对学校，前年是第六，没人会争辩说这不是一所狂欢的大校。
Well, look. We've never said we don't want our students to have fun.
听着。我们从没说过不希望学生们玩得开心。
The University's president, Graham Spanier, discussed the number one ranking in a faculty senate meeting this fall. The only recording that exist is from a webcast Penn State did at the meeting, so you hear the audio is little sketchy. But still fine.
大学校长格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔在秋季的一次教职工参议院会议上讨论了这一第一排名。唯一的录音来自宾州立大学在该会议上的网络广播，所以音频听起来有点粗糙。但还可以。
I mean, when people talk about oh, Penn State's a party school, I'm not-- it doesn't bother me at all, actually. I wish we weren't ranked number one.
我是说，当人们谈论噢，宾州立大学是派对学校时，我不——这其实一点也不困扰我。我只是希望我们没有被排在第一。
You know why we're ranked number one? Have we talked about this? You know why we're ranked number one? The students vote! It's not like somebody came in here and did an assessment of the place. It's an online, web-based thing. And whenever there's an online, web-based thing, Penn State always wins. We have the best mascot in the country. We probably do. But I guarantee that any online voting for the best mascot in the country, we're going to win that. You know? We're the number one university on Facebook. We're the number one university with Twitter.
你知道为什么我们被排在第一吗？我们谈过这个吗？你知道为什么我们被排在第一吗？是学生投的票！又不是有人亲自过来评估这个地方。这是一个基于网络的在线投票。只要是在线投票，宾州立大学总是赢。我们有全国最好的吉祥物。可能确实如此。但我敢保证，任何关于全国最佳吉祥物的在线投票，我们都会赢。你知道吗？我们在Facebook上是第一大学。我们在Twitter上是第一大学。
So when these party school things, some of our students get online and vote? Of course they want to be voted number one. Yeah, Penn State. Then I have to clean up the mess after the votes are in. Because I got all the donors and alumni, and the media I'm calling for comment.
所以当这些派对学校评选出现时，我们的学生就会上网投票？当然，他们想被选为第一。是的，宾州立大学。然后我必须在投票结果出来后清理烂摊子。因为我得应付所有的捐赠者、校友，还有媒体打电话来要评论。
The amount of drinking at the school does concern Spanier. He told the faculty that when people ask him what's the biggest problem at Penn State, they always expect him to say money, but the answer for a long time has been alcohol.
学校里的饮酒量确实让斯帕尼尔感到担忧。他告诉教职员工，当人们问他宾州立大学最大的问题是什么时，他们总是期望他说钱，但长期以来的答案一直是酒精。
And he said it's a problem that's bigger than Penn State. Nearly a third of high school seniors across the country binge drink.
他说这是一个比宾州立大学更大的问题。全国近三分之一的高中毕业生酗酒。
So it's a bit of a problem that we inherit. But we also have a cultural environment here, an atmosphere that fosters it.
所以这是一个我们继承下来的小问题。但我们这里也有一个文化环境，一种助长它的氛围。
Well, today we devote our entire show to the nation's number one party school. Not because it's number one and what happens here is unusual, but because it's not unusual at all. Lots of schools, especially a lot of big state schools, do this much partying.
今天，我们将整个节目献给全国第一派对学校。不是因为它排第一，也不是因为这里发生的事情不同寻常，而是因为它一点也不寻常。很多学校，尤其是很多大型州立大学，都有这么多的派对活动。
Five of us from our staff went down to State College where Sarah lives to record one football weekend in November. What we bring you today is a travelogue from this place where the rules and norms are probably very different from where you live right now. Its own rituals, its own jargon, its own native dress. We wanted to see what it was all about.
我们五名员工去了莎拉居住的州立学院，录制了11月的一个橄榄球周末。我们今天带给大家的是一个来自这个地方的游记，这里的规则和规范可能和你现在居住的地方非常不同。它有自己的仪式，自己的行话，自己的本地服装。我们想看看这到底是怎么回事。
Our show today, in four acts. Only three of them actually pre-soaked in vodka. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分四幕。只有其中三幕实际上是预先浸泡在伏特加里的。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One. I'm Not As Think As You Drunk I Am.
第一幕。我没醉到那种地步。
Let's start with the drinking, which is epic. The Harvard School of Public Health did a study of what schools tend to have the heaviest drinking, and Penn State actually hits all the criteria that they found. It's located in the northeast, and it has a large undergraduate population-- that would be, in this case, 44,000 students-- a large fraternity system, a nationally-known football team.
让我们从饮酒开始，这非常疯狂。哈佛公共卫生学院做了一项关于哪些学校倾向于最严重酗酒的研究，宾州立大学实际上符合他们发现的所有标准。它位于东北部，拥有大量的本科生群体——本案中是44,000名学生——庞大的兄弟会系统，还有一支全国知名的橄榄球队。
Now, the fact is that it probably doesn't hurt it's isolated. State College is in a valley nestled between two mountain ridges in a state forest. People here call it "Happy Valley." It's surrounded by farms. You're in the middle of nowhere, a few people said, without much to do but drink.
事实上，它很孤立可能没帮上忙。州立学院位于州森林中两条山脊之间的一个山谷里。这里的人称它为“快乐谷”。周围都是农场。有人说，你置身于荒郊野外，除了喝酒没别的事做。
And to talk about this drinking, I'm joined now in the studio by Sarah Koenig. Because Sarah, you recorded these first couple clips of tape.
关于这个饮酒问题，我现在在演播室里有莎拉·凯尼格加入。因为莎拉，你录制了最初的那几段录音。
Right. A couple of weeks before you guys came to State College, there was this huge freak snowstorm, and they had to cancel tailgating for the first time anyone could remember because the conditions were so dangerous by the field. But it didn't stop anyone. I saw people tailgating in their yards, on their front lawns. Even in my neighborhood, I saw people under, like, these building underpasses.
对。在你们来州立学院的前几周，发生了一场可怕的暴风雪，他们不得不取消了大家记忆中第一次的汽车后备箱派对，因为赛场周边的环境太危险了。但并没有阻止任何人。我看到人们在他们的院子里，在前草坪上举行派对。甚至在我家附近，我看到人们在像建筑通道下这样的地方。
I went into a parking garage and found all these people on the fourth floor. There's dirty cars everywhere. Concrete floor. It's cold, it's dark. At the end of one row of cars, there were these two tables pushed together in an L-shape tablecloths, and all kinds of food, and a couple of birthday cakes.
我走进一个停车场，发现四楼全是人。到处都是脏兮兮的车。水泥地面。又冷又暗。在一排车的尽头，有两张桌子拼在一起呈L型，上面铺着桌布，还有各种食物和几个生日蛋糕。
Whose birthday is this?
这是谁的生日？
It's my birthday! It's my birthday! My 21st birthday.
是我的生日！是我的生日！我21岁的生日。
Happy birthday!
生日快乐！
Thank you!
谢谢！
And what are you doing on the fourth floor of a parking garage?
你怎么在停车场的四楼？
I'm getting drunk and tailgating.
我在喝得烂醉，顺便参加派对。
Describe your headgear there.
描述一下你头上的装备。
It's a crown with a 21 that's on fire, and it says "Where is the bar?"
那是个带着火的21字样的皇冠，上面写着“酒吧在哪？”
So who brought all this food?
那谁带了这些食物？
My mom and dad, because they love me, and they're the best.
我爸爸妈妈，因为他们爱我，他们是最棒的。
About a half dozen older people were there, too. Her parents and some of their friends. And there were a bunch of other tailgates happening around us, and one couple was having their 40th wedding anniversary.
大约有半打年纪大的人也在那儿。她的父母和他们的一些朋友。我们周围还有很多其他派对正在进行，有一对夫妇正在庆祝他们的40周年结婚纪念日。
Wow. In the garage?
哇。在停车场？
In the garage, yeah. At one point, a women probably in her 50s walked up and handed the birthday girl a red plastic cup.
在停车场，是的。有个50岁左右的女人走过来，递给寿星一杯红色塑料杯。
Aw, thank you! What is this?
噢，谢谢！这是什么？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] Lemonade.
[听不清] 柠檬水。
Is there alcohol in it?
里面有酒精吗？
Most definitely.
那肯定。
Oh my God! This is the strongest drink I've ever had in my life. They just brought me a really strong alcoholic lemonade.
噢天哪！这是我这辈子喝过最烈的东西。她们刚刚给了我一杯非常强力的酒精柠檬水。
Is that your daughter, are you the mom?
那是你女儿吗，你是妈妈？
No, no.
不，不。
Oh. What's your--?
噢。那是你的——？
We're parked over there.
我们把车停在那边。
You just saw that this is happening.
你们只是看到这里在发生这些事。
Yes.
是的。
We've got to keep ourselves entertained somehow, right?
我们得给自己找点乐子，对吧？
Watch the 21 year old get plastered, that's the entertainment?
看这个21岁的孩子喝到烂醉，这就是娱乐？
Exactly, exactly.
正是，正是。
Thank you so much for the drink!
非常感谢你的这杯酒！
At tailgate parties, you see just how deeply embedded drinking is in life at Penn State. It's entire families. It's several generations together. It's outdoor, public drinking, which gives you the feeling, when you're there, that the whole world is drinking. Probably because there's so much of it.
在派对上，你可以看到饮酒在宾州立大学的生活中有多深厚。那是整个家庭。是好几代人在一起。这是户外的、公开的饮酒，当你身处其中时，会让你觉得全世界都在喝酒。可能是因为这种事太多了。
Penn State now has the largest stadium in North America. It holds over 100,000 people. The tailgates are these huge masses of humanity, spread out as far as you can see, all around the stadium. Starting at eight in the morning, starting really early, which is when these alums got here. They talked to one of our producers, Aaron Scott.
宾州立大学现在拥有北美最大的体育场。能容纳超过10万人。派对是巨大的人群，在你视线所及范围内铺开，分布在体育场周围。从早上8点开始，真的非常早，这就是那些校友到达的时间。他们和我们的制片人之一亚伦·斯科特聊了聊。
So you went to bed, three or four, you got up, and you're drinking again?
所以你睡了三四个小时，然后起床，又开始喝了？
Hells, yeah.
该死的，当然。
Is it ever too early to drink?
喝酒会太早吗？
Never.
绝不。
Eight in the morning means, by the way, that if it's a night game, they will tailgate for 12 hours, in the cold, in the freezing cold sometimes, before kickoff.
顺便说一句，早上8点意味着，如果是晚上的比赛，他们会在寒冷中，有时是在零下的寒冷中，在开球前参加12个小时的派对。
I talked to a bunch of alums at a tailgate about what would happen if they weren't allowed to drink at all.
我和一群校友谈论过，如果他们完全不被允许喝酒会怎样。
I think there would be a revolt. I think there would be a huge, huge pushback from the alumni that donate a lot of money to this school to say that you can't have alcohol at a tailgate.
我想会发生反抗。我认为那些给学校捐赠大量钱财的校友会强烈反对，说你不能在派对上喝酒。
That's Mark Johnson, class of 1977.
那是马克·约翰逊，1977届学生。
It's just part of the culture. I mean, that's why this school sells 110,000 tickets for every-- you know, just, it's a part of it. It's just part of that tradition.
这只是文化的一部分。我是说，这就是为什么这所学校每场比赛都能卖出11万张票——你知道，这只是其中一部分。这只是传统的一部分。
Usually pounding down drinks at eight in the morning can be kind of, I don't know, bad. But the main thing about this kind of drinking, where it's tied in with tradition, and football, and family, and overwhelming sense of school spirit, is that it feels incredibly wholesome. The whole campus feels like a Chevy commercial. Welcoming, people friendly. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
通常早上8点猛灌酒可能，我不知道，很不好。但关于这种饮酒的主要特点是，它与传统、橄榄球、家庭以及那种压倒性的学校精神联系在一起，它感觉非常健康。整个校园感觉就像雪佛兰的广告。热情好客，人们很友好。[听不清]
The sense that drinking together is what we do spills over from the football games into the whole weekend. Into the week, too, actually. It's Friday night, it's the night before the football game, outside East Hall, the big freshman dorms. Dozens of kids are lined up for free shuttle buses that are going to take them across campus to the frats and parties on the other side.
这种一起喝酒是我们生活方式的感觉从橄榄球比赛蔓延到整个周末。甚至实际上延伸到了平时。这是周五晚上，橄榄球比赛的前一天，在新生宿舍东大厅外。几十个孩子排队等着免费的穿梭巴士，带他们穿过校园去另一边的兄弟会和派对。
Two of our producers, Jane Feltes and Lisa Pollak, noticed that all the girls wore these ratty-looking hoodies and jackets over their dressup clothes. Somebody else told them support for this is "fracket," and wanted some girls to confirm that.
我们的两位制片人，简·费尔特斯和丽莎·波拉克，注意到所有的女孩在礼服外面都穿着这种破烂的连帽衫和外套。别人告诉她们这叫“兄弟会外套”，想让一些女孩确认一下。
Have you guys heard of something called "frackets"?
你们听说过叫“兄弟会外套”的东西吗？
Oh, yeah, that's what we're wearing. A fracket, by definition, is a jacket made for frats. It's basically a crappy jacket that's cheap and you don't care about.
噢，对，我们穿着呢。兄弟会外套，按定义，就是专为兄弟会派对而穿的外套。基本上就是那种便宜、破烂、你完全不在乎的外套。
Yeah. Because like, they get lost. They get, like, puked on. You don't want that back. You don't want it back. Just lose it. Yeah.
对。因为它们会丢。会被吐在上面。你根本不想要回它。你不想带它回来。丢了就丢了。没错。
Jane rode on the bus with the freshmen. She joins me now.
简和新生一起坐了车。她现在加入了我们。
So the reason that they needed the fracket in the first place, is it was really cold that night, and they're wearing next to nothing. All the girls had on pretty much the same thing. Like some version of a mini, mini, mini tube dress, bare legs, and super high platform heels. They all look like cocktail waitresses at a strip club.
所以她们一开始需要兄弟会外套的原因是，那天晚上真的非常冷，而她们穿的几乎什么都没有。所有的女孩穿的几乎都是一样的。某种迷你、迷你、迷你管状裙，光着腿，穿着超高防水台高跟鞋。她们看起来都像脱衣舞俱乐部的鸡尾酒女侍应。
Did you guys dress like this in high school.
你们高中时穿成这样吗？
Uh, no. We just got slutty after we got into college.
呃，没有。我们只是上了大学才变浪的。
My dress-- yeah, it's pretty short. It like barely covers my, like, tuckus, so.
我的裙子——对，真的很短。它几乎盖不住我的，呃，屁股，所以。
That girl, her name's Chuy, She's from Saudi Arabia. Guess that's the word they use for that over there.
那个女孩，她叫楚伊，她来自沙特阿拉伯。猜那是她们那边用的词。
Yeah, right.
对，没错。
When I met her and her friend Megna, they were already on their second loop around campus. They were kind of drunk and they'd missed their stop the first time.
当我遇到她和她的朋友梅格娜时，她们已经在校园里兜第二圈了。她们有点醉了，第一次就错过了站。
And on this bus, everyone keeps breaking into song.
而在公共汽车上，每个人都在不断地唱歌。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
What is happening?
怎么回事？
This is the drunk bus. Good timing.
这是醉酒巴士。时间刚刚好。
Oh my God. Is this the same stop where we found out that we were late?
噢天哪。这是我们发现我们迟到的那一站吗？
Penn State's administration does a pretty thorough job surveying students to track how much they're drinking. The surveys show that every Friday and every Saturday night, 75% of the school drinks. That's over 30,000 people, an average of four and a half drinks per person. And the students drink those drinks in about three hours average.
宾州立大学的管理层非常彻底地调查学生，追踪他们的饮酒量。调查显示，每个周五和周六晚上，75%的学校在喝酒。那是超过3万人，每人平均喝四杯半。而学生们平均在三个小时内喝掉这些酒。
To put those numbers in perspective, binge drinking, or as it's being re-branded lately, high risk or dangerous drinking, defined as four drinks for a woman or five drinks for a man consumed in just two hours.
为了从角度理解这些数字，酗酒，或者最近被重新定义为高风险或危险饮酒，被定义为女性喝四杯或男性喝五杯，仅在两小时内消费完。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
When you get down into the details of Penn State's numbers, it works out to over half the students regularly binge drinking, which is just a little bit above the national average for college students.
当你深入了解宾州立大学的具体数字时，算出超过一半的学生经常酗酒，这仅仅比全国大学生的平均水平高出一点点。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
The routine at Penn State on weekend nights is that you pregame or preload. That's what they call it when you drink at your apartment or your dorm room before going out. It's way cheaper than buying drinks at a bar. Also in winter, keeps you warm. We heard lots of people use the phrase "beer jacket."
宾州立大学周末晚上的惯例是预热或载入。这就是他们所说的在出门前在公寓或宿舍喝酒。这比在酒吧买酒便宜得多。而且在冬天，还能保暖。我们听很多人用“啤酒外套”这个词。
And if you went to college long ago, you definitely noticed mostly hard liquor here, not beer. Various sugary vodka drinks of various kinds. Red bull and vodka, one of them. So everybody gets a lot more drunk.
如果你很久以前上过大学，你肯定注意到这里主要是烈酒，不是啤酒。各种各样的含糖伏特加饮料。红牛加伏特加是其中一种。所以每个人都喝得更醉。
To living single, to seeing double.
为了单身生活，为了看东西重影。
Oh. And what's the triple?
噢。那三倍是什么？
Early on one night, I went to an apartment with a bunch of seniors. And they were getting ready and pregaming. They said they usually do five shots in five minutes before they leave the house. There were empties everywhere.
有一天晚上早些时候，我去了个有一群大四学生的公寓。他们正在准备和预热。他们说出门前通常会在五分钟内喝五杯。到处都是空酒瓶。
That's not bad.
那还不错。
Oh, yum.
噢，好吃。
What's in your fridge?
你冰箱里有什么？
Um, water, lemonade, tequila, Malibu, vodka, margarita mix, and cheese.
呃，水、柠檬水、龙舌兰、马利宝、伏特加、玛格丽特预调酒和奶酪。
But college students are underage, so a lot, maybe most, of drinking at Penn State is underage drinking. The bars in State College are actually very strict about under 21 drinking. You have to show a student ID. In lots of places they scan the ID. But there are other ways to get drunk. Everybody told us if you're too young for a bar, you go to a frat party.
但大学生还没成年，所以很多，也许大部分在宾州立大学的饮酒是未成年饮酒。州立学院的酒吧实际上对21岁以下的饮酒非常严格。你必须出示学生证。在很多地方他们扫描ID。但还有其他方法喝醉。每个人都告诉我们，如果你还没到酒吧的年龄，你就去兄弟会派对。
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。
Back up, three steps.
退后三步。
Why should we let you in this party?
为什么我们要让你进这个派对？
Thursday night. This is the front door of a fraternity that asked that I not use their name. Under Penn State rules, nobody is supposed to get into a frat party except members of other fraternities and sororities, and guys on an official university list of potential pledges. There's supposed to be a guest list with names at the door. But in practice, it seems like pretty much any cute girl can get onto that guest list on the spot. Which is one reason they all wear the miniskirts, one girl told us. To help with that.
周四晚上。这是个不希望我使用他们名字的兄弟会的前门。根据宾州立大学的规则，除了其他兄弟会和姐妹会的成员，以及大学正式名单上的潜在预备成员，任何人都不准进入兄弟会派对。门口应该有一份带着名字的来宾名单。但实际上，似乎任何可爱的女孩都能现场加入那份名单。这也是她们都穿迷你裙的一个原因，一个女孩告诉我们。为了帮忙进入。
So he has to come with me because I'm wearing his jacket.
所以他得跟我一起来，因为我穿着他的外套。
This particular girl, though, had a guy with her that the brothers did not want to let in.
不过这个女孩带了一个兄弟会成员不想放进去的家伙。
He's important.
他很重要。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
Are you serious? You're going to leave him all alone? Look at him. He's so innocent. Look at his face.
你是认真的吗？你要把他一个人留在这里？看看他。他多天真。看看他的脸。
Is he in a frat?
他是兄弟会成员吗？
Yeah!
是啊！
What frat, though?
哪个兄弟会？
He's one of my best friends! Come on.
他是我最好的朋友之一！快点。
What frat is he in?
他是哪个兄弟会的？
He's my best friend.
他是我最好的朋友。
He's not in a frat, so under school rules, he should not be let in. But the guys at the door are no match for this girl.
他不是兄弟会成员，所以根据校规，他不应该被放进来。但门口的家伙根本不是这个女孩的对手。
Yo, dude, sorry. You can go in. Go in, just go in, dude.
哟，哥们，抱歉。你可以进去了。进去吧，进去吧，哥们。
And another young drinker finds haven.
又一个年轻的饮酒者找到了避难所。
Inside the windows are taped over with plastic trash bags, which gives the whole place the feeling of a seedy underground club. One big room is dark with a DJ and a big sound system, dancing. Another room has booze. The floor of this room is slippery with a layer of muck that is part beer, part dirt, part, you know.
里面窗户用塑料垃圾袋封着，这让整个地方感觉像个肮脏的地下俱乐部。一个大房间很暗，有DJ和巨大的音响系统，在跳舞。另一个房间有酒。这个房间的地板上铺着一层滑腻腻的淤泥，一部分是啤酒，一部分是泥土，一部分，你懂的。
There's a lot of flirting. Much of it ineffective. I walked up to one couple who told me they'd been talking for half an hour.
有很多调情。大部分是无效的。我走近一对告诉我他们聊了半小时的情侣。
Did you know this guy before you came?
来之前你认识这男的吗？
No. It's not weird. And I'm not trying to get away from him. Why all the people I meet here are weird.
不。这并不奇怪。我也不是在试图躲开他。为什么我在这儿遇到的人都这么奇怪。
Really?
真的吗？
Like him. He's really awkward. I don't know. This is kind of awkward.
像他这样。他真的很尴尬。我不知道。这真有点尴尬。
I'm just trying to get her drunk so I can take advantage of her later.
我只是在试图灌醉她，这样以后可以占她便宜。
That's awkward!
那真尴尬！
I know. I'm working on it.
我知道。我正努力呢。
The whole time we were at Penn State, I found myself looking back and forth between two opposite feelings about all the drinking I saw going on. Sometimes it seemed really extreme. Other times it seemed like, so what. Kids drink at college. Most of them get through it. Lots of students said something that was hard argue with. When else are they going to get a chance to do this? Like I was talking to a senior by the back door of the fraternity about this and that.
在宾州立大学的整个过程中，我发现自己在两种相反的感觉之间来回徘徊。有时它看起来真的很极端。其他时候它看起来，那又怎样。孩子在大学喝酒。他们大部分人都能熬过去。很多学生说了一些很难反驳的话。他们什么时候还能有这种机会呢？就像我在兄弟会后门和一个大四学生谈论这些那些一样。
So what's the wildest thing you've seen at a party at this school?
那你在这学校派对上见过最狂野的事情是什么？
Wildest thing? At a party? Somebody stripping completely naked and pretending to throw monkey feces as they were doing it. And--that was me.
最狂野的事？在派对上？有人彻底脱光，在这么做的时候假装扔猴子粪便。而且——那个人就是我。
That was you?
那个人是你？
That was me.
那个人就是我。
When was that?
那是什么时候？
Last week.
上周。
Last week?
上周？
Somebody I was like, yeah, I dare you to get naked. I'm just like, I'll get naked. It was really fun.
有人跟我说，嘿，我敢你脱光。我就像，我会脱光的。这真的很有趣。
I mean, you can only do that stuff now, when you're in college. You know? I wouldn't be able to do it six months from now. [BLEEP] it. You know, it's college.
我是说，你只能在现在，在大学的时候做这种事。你知道吗？六个月后我就做不到了。[消音]的。你知道，这就是大学。
It's also not hard to find students who talk about the darker side of all this partying. A senior named Dan was out late one of these weekend nights, not drinking, but watching drunk people and taking notes for a paper that he's writing. He decided to quit his fraternity after his sophomore year because he was falling so far behind in the school work. His frat threw parties not two, not three, but four nights a week, which is typical here.
找到谈论这种狂欢阴暗面的学生也不难。一个叫丹的大四学生在某个周末晚上出门很晚，他没喝酒，而是在观察醉酒的人，为他写的一篇论文做笔记。他在大二后决定退出他的兄弟会，因为他的学业掉队太多了。他的兄弟会每周派对不仅两三次，而是四次，这在这里很典型。
Every Thursday, Friday, Saturday, huge parties. Something every Wednesday. And then all the other days, something going on. You know, come in from a day of class, and you know, my three or four best friends are all playing beer pong, for instance. It got to the point where I was like, this isn't a good place for me to be to achieve. You know, there are nights that I'd have to wear my headphones to try to study because it would be so loud, and just live in the library most of the time. You know, I've had to cut the circuit breaker on people's rooms before, because it's four AM and they won't turn off their music. And you see fights. You know, I've seen people sent to the hospital for things as petty as, you knocked my drink out of my hand. I saw a kid stop breathing from alcohol poisoning. It's all-- it's amazing, the things that go on there. That it operates legally, I find, is incredible.
每周四、周五、周六，巨大的派对。每周三也有活动。然后其他日子，总有什么在发生。你知道，从一天的课里回来，你知道，我最好的三四个朋友都在玩啤酒乒乓球。情况变得糟糕到我心想，这不是我实现目标的好地方。你知道，有些晚上我得戴着耳机尝试学习，因为太吵了，而且大部分时间得住在图书馆。你知道，我以前不得不拉断别人房间的断路器，因为凌晨四点他们不关音乐。而且你会看到打架。你知道，我见过有人因为鸡毛蒜皮的事——你把我的酒杯撞掉了——就被送进医院。我看到一个孩子因为酒精中毒停止呼吸。这一切——真令人惊奇，这里发生的事情。它居然能合法运作，我觉得不可思议。
In the surveys of students done by the school, a fourth of Penn State students say that drinking has caused them to miss class get behind with their school work. 15% say they've been pushed, hit, or assaulted. 7% said drinking lead to an unwanted sexual experience. 6% said they'd gotten into what you would call a real, physical fight. And there are crimes that you never hear of unless you live in a place like State College.
在学校做的学生调查中，四分之一的宾州立大学学生说饮酒导致他们缺课，学业落后。15%说他们被推挤、殴打或侵犯。7%说饮酒导致了不想要的性经历。6%说他们卷入了所谓的真正的身体冲突。而且有些犯罪，除非你住在州立学院这样的地方，否则你永远不会听说。
Our daughter came into the kitchen while we were in the midst of hurriedly getting everything done and said something to the effect of, Mommy, I want to play in my room. Can you please get that man out of my bed? And I remember having said something to the effect of, there's no man in your bed. And she actually went away and came back a few minutes later. So I guess she went up to check, and she comes down. There is a man in my bed, and I want to play in my room. Would you please get him out of there?
当我们在匆忙完成事情时，我们的女儿走进厨房说：“妈妈，我想在我的房间玩。你能请那个男人离开我的床吗？”我记得我说了类似“你床上没有男人”的话。她竟然走开了，几分钟后又回来了。所以我想她去看了看，她回来时说：“床上的确有个男人，我想在我的房间玩。请你让他离开那儿好吗？”
This is a long time State College resident named Nina White. And the man on the bed, of course, was a college student who committed a surprisingly common crime in this town. He came to her house drunk, found a comfortable place, and fell asleep.
这是一位在州立学院住了很久的居民，叫妮娜·怀特。床上的那个男人，当然，是一个在这个镇上犯了惊人普遍罪行的大学生。他喝醉了来她家，找了个舒服的地方，睡着了。
Because of incidents like this, the population at Penn State who seem the most exercised about student drinking right now is local residents who live near the students. They've been organizing and trying to pass new laws. Some of them admit that dealing with so many drunk kids so many months in a row has turned them into something that they are not proud to be. One neighbor, Laird Jones, told me he knows it's driving him a little batty.
由于这类事件，宾州立大学人口中现在似乎对学生饮酒最激进的是住在学生附近的当地居民。他们一直在组织并试图通过新法律。他们中有些人承认，连续几个月面对这么多醉酒孩子已经把他们变成了一种他们并不引以为傲的样子。一位邻居，莱尔德·琼斯，告诉我他知道这快把他逼疯了。
I don't know if you heard when you came in, but I have motion sensors out there. So I can hear an alarm, and I know which point in the yard they came in, so I can just see what's going on.
不知道你进来时听到了没，但我外面有运动传感器。所以我能听到报警声，而且我知道他们从院子的哪个点进来的，所以我能看到发生了什么。
Glaird lives right in the middle of the fraternities, right on the same block. And he puts up with so much noise, and so many kids kicking in his fence, and drenching his yard with pee, and so many incidents with bloody kids, injured kids, kids who are high, parties next door with hundreds of kids that wouldn't end, then he delivered these all like a series of the macabre one-liners in the most disturbing stand-up act ever. Sample?
莱尔德就住在兄弟会中间，就在同一个街区。他忍受了太多的噪音，太多孩子踢坏他的栅栏，把他的院子尿湿，还有太多带着血的孩子、受伤的孩子、嗑药的孩子、隔壁住着数百个不肯散去的孩子的派对事件，然后他用最令人不安的单口相声表演交付了这些像恐怖小段子一样的话。样本？
One of the things you learn here in your yard is if you see a tampon, you have to get a stick and find the condom.
你在院子里学到的其中一件事是，如果你看到卫生棉条，你必须拿根棍子找到避孕套。
That is so gross.
那真恶心。
I think I'm a lot more callous about human suffering, and I've sort of taken this attitude that the only way they're going to learn is to get hurt. I mean, I was walking home with my son on Sunday, past the frat house up the street. And for fun, they were throwing furniture off the roof. Which is actually kind of fun. It's just, when it all hit the ground, they got out lighter fluid and soaked it and lit it on fire. In a yard full of dry leaves ten feet away from a parked car.
我觉得我对人类苦难变得冷漠多了，而且我采取了一种态度，即他们学习的唯一方法是受到伤害。我是说，我周日带儿子回家时，路过街上的兄弟会房子。出于娱乐，他们正把家具从屋顶扔下来。这其实还挺好玩的。只是，当它落到地上时，他们拿出了打火机油，浸湿了它并点火。在一个离停着的车只有十英尺远、满是干枯树叶的院子里。
And I thought to myself, you know, should I call? Or should I just get my son out of the way let them learn?
我对自己心想，你知道，我是该报警？还是该带儿子走开，让他们吸取教训？
That buzzing, of course, was the motion-activated sensors pointed at his yard.
那阵嗡嗡声，当然，就是指向他院子的运动激活传感器。
For now, anyway, most of the students seem to go to classes, get an education, and drink pretty happily. And the people who are learning something, and changing, and making resolutions because of the drinking so far mostly seem to be the neighbors.
至少现在，大部分学生似乎还是会去上课，接受教育，并且快乐地喝酒。而那些因为饮酒正在学习、改变并做出决心的人，目前看来主要是邻居们。
Coming up-- why delivery guys don't like to deliver Buffalo wings in State College, Pennsylvania. Also--
接下来——为什么送餐员不喜欢在宾夕法尼亚州州立学院送布法罗辣鸡翅。还有——
[GROWL]
[低吼]
Thank you, mountain lion. Have we mentioned that the name of the football team is the Nittany Lions? I know a lot of you knew that anyway. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
谢谢你，美洲狮。我们提过橄榄球队的名字叫尼塔尼雄狮吗？我知道你们很多人本来就知道。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "#1 Party School." We spent a football weekend at Penn State University to see life at one of the big partying state schools. We have now arrived at Act Two.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选一个主题，带给大家关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“第一派对学校”。我们在宾州立大学度过了一个橄榄球周末，看看大型派对州立学校的生活。我们现在到了第二幕。
Act Two. "If God Isn't a Penn State Fan, Then Why is The Sky Blue and White."
第二幕。“如果上帝不是宾州立大学的粉丝，那天空为什么是蓝白相间的。”
All of our names today, by the way, are things seen on bumper stickers, T-shirts, and shot glasses in the State College area.
顺便说一句，我们今天提到的所有名字都是在州立学院地区看到的保险杠贴纸、T恤和酒杯上的东西。
One of the ways that the town of State College is actually an unusual, special place, its own little kind of cultural ecosystem, like a little microclimate in the middle of Pennsylvania, is that because of the University, it is in only county in the state whose GDP grew in 2008. It also has the lowest unemployment rate of any county in the state.
州立学院这个城镇作为一个不寻常、特殊的地方，它自己小小的文化生态系统，就像宾夕法尼亚州中部的一个小微气候，因为大学的原因，它是州内2008年GDP唯一增长的县。它也有州内所有县中最低的失业率。
Part of this prosperity is because the University is growing. Enrollment is up, even during the recession. But one member of our staff, Nancy Updike, spent a few days going around to area businesses, and she found that they have adapted to the very specialized needs of the nation's number one party school. Here's what you learned.
这种繁荣的部分原因是大学在成长。招生人数在上升，即使在经济衰退期间也是如此。但我们的一名员工，南希·厄普代克，花了几天时间走访当地企业，她发现他们已经适应了全国第一派对学校非常特殊的需求。这是你学到的。
Here are six tips for running a business in State College, PA. Six tips, all kinds of businesses, with supporting illustrations. Tip one. Keep up.
这里是在宾州州立学院经营企业的六个建议。六个建议，各种企业，附带说明。建议一。跟上。
This is McLanahan's, a sprawling Hearst Castle of a store. It's your basic drugstore- deli- produce market- hardware- underwear- beer pong- stationary- grocery- Penn State merchandise emporium, which over the years has acquired and absorbed the stores that used to be next to it to the point where it's bought up everything it can, and the only way left to expand is to cram more stuff everywhere. And there's always something clamoring for more space.
这是麦克拉纳汉商店，一家像赫斯特城堡一样的巨大商店。这是你基本的药店-熟食店-农产品市场-五金店-内衣-啤酒乒乓球-文具-杂货-宾州立大学商品百货，多年来它收购并吸收了以前旁边的商店，以至于它买下了能买的一切，剩下的扩展方法就是把更多东西塞到各处。而且总有东西在吵着要更多空间。
McLanahan's owner Ray Agostinelli says that over and over again, he's had to stock way up on some usually sleepy object that has suddenly become a crazy hot seller.
麦克拉纳汉商店的老板雷·阿戈斯蒂内利说，一次又一次，他不得不囤积大量通常乏人问津的物品，这些物品突然变成了疯抢的畅销货。
Well, it happened one time with marshmallows. And all of a sudden, all the marshmallows were gone. And here what it was, is that they'd take them to the football games, and they were throwing marshmallows.
好吧，有一次棉花糖发生了这种情况。突然之间，所有的棉花糖都没了。原来是他们把它们带到橄榄球比赛中，他们在扔棉花糖。
You said people were throwing marshmallows onto the field?
你说人们在往场上扔棉花糖？
Oh yeah, they were getting pretty dangerous with them. This wasn't too good. And they got outlawed. But the kids would come in and buy all the marshmallows, and we said, wait a minute. We never sold them any marshmallows. What? But just whatever the crazes are, you have to keep up with and be there.
噢是的，他们用它们变得非常危险。这可不太好。它们被取缔了。但孩子们会进来买光所有的棉花糖，我们说，等一下。我们从没卖过他们棉花糖。什么？但无论流行什么，你都必须跟上并出现在那里。
And then there are the crazes that never go away. Sex. One of the McLanahan's many frank and non-judgmental offerings is its display right out front that is condoms on top, lubricant in the middle, pregnancy tests on the bottom.
还有那些永不消逝的热潮。性。麦克拉纳汉商店众多坦率且不加评判的商品之一是门口的展示架，上面是避孕套，中间是润滑剂，底部是验孕棒。
Ray takes me into one of the two Penn State merchandise sections of the store. It's a full sensory experience. That's a CD of the school's band in the background. There seven different kinds of car air fresheners with the Penn State logo, pacifiers, a steering wheel cover.
雷带我进入商店的两个宾州立大学商品区之一。这是全方位的感官体验。背景里是学校乐队的CD。有七种带有宾州立大学标志的汽车空气清新剂，奶嘴，方向盘套。
Ray, are you ever amazed at something, you never knew that the Penn State logo could be put on it? I just saw a remote control, a TV remote.
雷，你有没有对什么感到惊讶，你从未想到宾州立大学标志能印在上面？我刚刚看到一个遥控器，电视遥控器。
You put it on here and it will sell. You put it on your microphone, it will sell.
你印上去，它就能卖。你印在麦克风上，它也能卖。
In the almost 50 years Ray has been working at McLanahan's-- he bought it from Bob McLanahan 40 years ago-- Ray has seen the Penn State merchandise in his store go from almost an afterthought, maybe one rack of sweatshirts, to being a third of his business. The only downside is--
在雷为麦克拉纳汉商店工作将近50年的时间里——他40年前从鲍勃·麦克拉纳汉手里买下了它——雷见证了店里的宾州立大学商品从几乎是事后的想法，可能只有一个架子的运动衫，到占他业务的三分之一。唯一的缺点是——
If Penn State would have a losing season, sales drop dramatically.
如果宾州立大学有一个输掉的赛季，销售额会急剧下降。
Oh, is that true?
噢，那是真的吗？
Oh my gosh. You can't imagine. You can't imagine.
噢天哪。你无法想象。你无法想象。
Ray says if Penn State loses one football game, sales of Penn State merch at McLanahan's go down 20%. Not for a day, for a week. And sometimes even longer, until the next winning game.
雷说如果宾州立大学输了一场橄榄球比赛，麦克拉纳汉商店的宾州立大学商品销售额会下降20%。不是一天，是一周。有时甚至更长，直到下一场胜利的比赛。
Which brings us to Marrara's, the dry cleaner up the street. Just about every business owner and employee I talked to said business was significantly down because of Penn State's loss to Ohio State the week before. But at the dry cleaner, no mention of this. Parties happen every weekend, win or lose, and that means some people will end up talking to Roberta at Marrara's, who after 18 years at the store is functionally psychic.
这就把我们引向了街上的马拉拉干洗店。我交谈过的几乎每个企业主和员工都说因为宾州立大学上周输给俄亥俄州立大学，业务大幅下滑。但在干洗店，没提这事。派对每个周末都会发生，无论输赢，这意味着有些人最终会和马拉拉的罗伯塔交谈，在店里工作18年后，她实际上有通灵能力。
You know, if they've thrown up or something like that, they're not going to admit that that's what has happened.
你知道，如果他们吐了或者类似的事情，他们不会承认发生了什么。
Do you have a way of telling if it's-- you're nodding. Yes, I have ways. What is--
你有什么办法分辨吗？你点着头。是的，我有办法。那是什么——
Well, if they put it in a plastic bag, the garment's in a plastic bag, and they don't want to open it, I don't want to open it, either.
好吧，如果他们把它放在塑料袋里，衣服在塑料袋里，而他们不想打开它，我也不想打开。
Is that what you tell them, literally? If you don't want to take it out, I don't want to take it out?
这就是你字面上告诉他们的？如果你不想拿出来，我也不想拿出来？
Right. We won't clean anything that has vomit or animal urine or anything like that on it.
对。我们不会清洗任何有呕吐物或动物尿液或类似东西的衣服。
In case anyone's wondering, women students usually bring the vomit, male students the urine, animal or otherwise.
如果有人想知道，女学生通常带来呕吐物，男学生带来尿液，动物或其他。
So second tip. Apply the smell test.
所以第二个建议。应用气味测试。
Third tip. When it's late, simplify.
第三个建议。当时间很晚时，简化。
Every Friday and Saturday night after midnight, when the drink specials at the bars are over, Canyon Pizza starts getting a loud, amped-up line of students down the block. The business model at Canyon Pizza is straight-up, no-frills genius. Slices are a dollar a piece. After 11 PM, it's cheese only. And every time the pretty women behind the counter get a tip, they hit a giant tip gong.
每个周五和周六午夜过后，当酒吧的酒水特价结束后，峡谷披萨店门口就会排起长长一队兴奋的学生。峡谷披萨店的商业模式是直接、无修饰的天才。每片披萨一块钱。晚上11点后，只供应芝士味的。每当柜台后的漂亮女员工收到小费，她们就敲一个巨大的小费锣。
Canyon Pizza also delivers until four in the morning on weekends, and the deliveries are a whole separate world, deserving their own business tip. So tip four-- be aware of fists and wings.
峡谷披萨店周末也一直送货到凌晨四点，送货完全是另一个世界，值得有自己的商业建议。所以建议四——留意拳头和鸡翅。
One of the delivery guys is Alex Moore. He's going on a run in his black Saturn Ion, which was new when he started doing deliveries almost three years ago, but it's taking some abuse after being parked in front of Canyon Pizza and its nighttime crowds weekend after weekend.
其中一名送餐员是亚历克斯·摩尔。他正开着他的黑色土星离子车，这辆车在他开始送货快三年时还是新的，但在周末一次又一次地停在峡谷披萨店及其深夜人群面前后，它受到了一些损耗。
I'm actually working on a Canyon Pizza video game. Yeah, I'm serious. It's called "30 Minutes or Less."
我其实在做一款峡谷披萨店的电子游戏。真的，我是认真的。它叫“30分钟或更少”。
The point to deliver a pizza through all sorts of obstacles?
重点是通过各种障碍物递送披萨？
Yep. The point is deliver pizza. You know, you have to avoid all the drunk people, and when they do stuff to your car and stuff, you've got to pay for it. All kinds of-- very realistic delivery driving game. People throw ranch all over my car. I have footprints on the back of my car right now because some kid was jumping up and down on it.
对。重点是递送披萨。你知道，你必须避开所有的醉酒人群，当他们对你的车做手脚时，你得自己买单。各种各样——非常真实的送餐驾驶游戏。人们把牧场酱到处扔在我的车上。我现在车的后面有脚印，因为某个小孩在上面跳来跳去。
You say ranch, like ranch dressing?
你说牧场酱，是像牧场色拉酱？
Yeah. It rots the paint off your car. And people spit all over my car pretty much every night. And yeah. Someone kicked in this window, so it doesn't roll down correctly anymore. Recently some kid broke my jaw.
对。它会烂掉车上的漆。而且人们几乎每天晚上都对着我的车吐唾沫。而且是的。有人踢坏了这扇窗户，所以它现在不能正常卷下来了。最近某个小孩打碎了我的下巴。
Oh my God, Alex!
噢天哪，亚历克斯！
Yeah. His friend was punching dents in one of the other delivery' driver's cars and I went to chase him down. Some random kid broke my jaw on the way. So I had to have my jaw wired shut for two months.
是啊。他的朋友正在猛砸另一名送餐员的车，我去追他。半路上有个随机小孩打碎了我的下巴。所以我不得不把下巴接上线，闭了两个月嘴。
Oh my God.
噢天哪。
Yeah. So I got stories. One second.
是啊。所以我有故事。一秒钟。
Alex stops to deliver a pizza. Actually two extra larges and pepperoni rolls. He says he's never had a drink in his life. Just not interested.
亚历克斯停下送披萨。实际上是两个超大号的还有意大利辣香肠卷。他说他这辈子没喝过酒。只是没兴趣。
Alex is 22. He's studying game simulation and computer programming at DeVry online. Look closely at his hoodie. It's Pac-Man.
亚历克斯22岁。他在DeVry在线学习游戏模拟和计算机编程。仔细看看他的连帽衫。是吃豆人。
Pizza delivery has been a good job while he's finishing up his degree. The only food Alex says he doesn't like to deliver is wings. Canyon Pizza has a sister store, Canyon Wings, and Alex says that mysteriously, people don't tip for wings. He says most of the time he gets a dollar or nothing at all. Just stiffed.
在完成学位期间，送披萨一直是个好工作。亚历克斯说他唯一不喜欢送的食物是鸡翅。峡谷披萨店有家姐妹店，峡谷鸡翅，亚历克斯说神秘的是，人们不给鸡翅小费。他说大部分时间他得到一美元或根本没有。只是被放鸽子了。
Which is a bummer.
这真是扫兴。
On wings.
在鸡翅上。
Yeah. And the only reason I say that is because I had a friend who worked at Damons who delivered wings too, and he got the same thing. A dollar or stiffed. I don't know. It must just be a thing with wings. I really don't know.
对。我这么说的唯一原因是，我有个在达蒙斯工作的朋友也送鸡翅，他得到的一样。一美元或被放鸽子。我不知道。那肯定只是鸡翅的事。我真不知道。
Tip five. Keep it cheap.
建议五。保持便宜。
In Pennsylvania, beer is only sold in certain stores. It's not sold in grocery stores, and it's not sold in the places that sell liquor and wine. This is just how Pennsylvania does things. It's been this way since the end of Prohibition.
在宾夕法尼亚州，啤酒只在特定的商店出售。它不在杂货店出售，也不在销售烈酒和葡萄酒的地方出售。这就是宾夕法尼亚州做事情的方式。自从禁酒令结束以来一直这样。
So Paul Pletcher owns Pletcher's, one of the beer stores in State College. It's a family business. Paul's father lured him away from teaching middle school math. And over the last 15 years or so, Paul has witnessed a strange trend in student drinking-- the ascendance, and eventual dominance, of light beer. As Paul remembers it, it went from Coors Light to Miller Lite to Bud Light and now--
所以保罗·普莱彻拥有普莱彻啤酒商店，这是州立学院的啤酒商店之一。这是家族生意。保罗的父亲诱使他离开中学数学教学。在过去的15年左右，保罗目睹了学生饮酒的一个奇怪趋势——淡啤酒的兴起，以及最终的统治地位。正如保罗记忆中的，它从库尔斯淡啤变成米勒淡啤，到百威淡啤，现在——
The most popular beer in State College right now I believe is Natural Light. It's inexpensive and very popular among the students.
我相信现在州立学院最流行的啤酒是天然淡啤。它不贵，在学生中很受欢迎。
Natural Light, aka Natty Light, is way beyond "very popular" among Penn State students. It laps every other beer. Even though apparently no one likes it, including the students at Pletcher's who are buying it.
天然淡啤，又名Natty Light，在宾州立大学的学生中不仅仅是“非常流行”。它超越了所有其他啤酒。尽管显然没有人喜欢它，包括在普莱彻买它的学生。
It's pretty bad.
这挺糟糕的。
But you have three cases of it.
但你买了三箱。
Well, it's not for me. It's for my friends.
好吧，这又不是给我的。是给朋友的。
Only in college can you show up with a beer your friends know is bad and still be a hero. Natty Light's sole virtue-- this is according to its own customers-- is that it's cheap. $16.50 a case at Pletcher's. No one, not a single person I talked to, liked the taste.
只有在大学里，你才能带着朋友明知很难喝的啤酒出现，却还能成为英雄。天然淡啤唯一的优点——这是根据它自己的顾客说的——就是它便宜。在普莱彻卖16.50美元一箱。没有人，我交谈过的没一个人，喜欢它的味道。
It's terrible.
太可怕了。
This group of students said that at their party and tailgate, they would have the six cases of Natty Light they were buying, plus another favorite drink, Jungle Juice, which is also--
这群学生说，在他们的派对和派对上，他们会有买的六箱天然淡啤，外加另一种最喜欢的饮料，丛林果汁，这也是——
Oh, it's horrible. It's like a lot of Hawaiian Punch, orange juice, pineapple juice, and then two handles of Vladimir Vodka, which is the worst vodka you can possibly get. That's what I lived on freshman year. It's terrible.
噢，太恐怖了。就像很多夏威夷潘趣酒、橙汁、菠萝汁，然后两瓶弗拉基米尔伏特加，那是你能买到最烂的伏特加。我大一就是靠那个活下来的。太糟糕了。
So basically I'm getting a picture of Penn State that you spend 70% of your time drinking things that you find absolutely repulsive.
所以基本上我得到了一幅宾州立大学的画卷，你花70%的时间喝着你觉得绝对恶心的东西。
Yeah. We like the way they make us feel.
对。我们喜欢它们带给我们的感觉。
If there was a drunk button-
如果有个醉酒按钮——
Did you catch that? He said, if there was a drunk button--
你听到了吗？他说，如果有个醉酒按钮——
If there was a drunk button, I would buy one.
如果有个醉酒按钮，我会买一个。
Press the button.
按下按钮。
Just for the record, if it'd been available, I would have used the drunk button in college.
顺便说一句，如果当时有的话，我在大学时也会用那个醉酒按钮。
Tip six. Like your customers.
建议六。喜欢你的顾客。
There's a bar just up the street from Canyon Pizza called The Brewery. It's a dive. Literally. It's in a basement. The main owner is Ray Rocky who grew up in Pennsylvania and went to Penn State undergrad and grad school. He started tending bar as a student.
从峡谷披萨店往上走有一家叫“啤酒厂”的酒吧。这是个潜水酒吧。字面意思。它在地下室。主要老板是雷·罗基，他在宾夕法尼亚州长大，上了宾州立大学的本科和研究生。他学生时代就开始在酒吧打工。
When I got the business like 17, 18 years ago, we were probably 80%, 85% beer in sales over the bar. Now we're probably 80% to 90% liquor.
我接手这业务大概17、18年前，酒吧销售额的80%、85%可能是啤酒。现在大概80%到90%是烈酒。
It's completely shifted.
完全变了。
Yeah.
是的。
Ray says there are many reasons for this tectonic change in student drinking habits. He says beer is at a disadvantage at the University generally since Penn State banned kegs at fraternities, dorms, and tailgates.
雷说学生饮酒习惯发生这种巨大变化有很多原因。他说啤酒在大学总体上处于劣势，因为宾州立大学禁止在兄弟会、宿舍和汽车后备箱派对上使用小桶。
And Ray says in his experience, promotional reps for liquors like Bacardi or Captain Morgan do a lot more on-site promotions, giving away T-shirts and such, than beer labels do. And the promotions work. They push sales toward liquor.
雷说根据他的经验，百加得或摩根船长等烈酒的推广代表比啤酒品牌做更多的现场推广，赠送T恤等。而且推广有效。它们推动了烈酒的销售。
There's also lots of liquor now that's flavored-- more fruit punch than bourbon. And Ray says the 21 year olds he sees in his bar seem to come in already much more used to drinking liquor than beer. It mixes well with soda or red bull, and it's easier to hide.
现在也有很多调味烈酒——与其说是波本酒不如说是水果潘趣酒。雷说他在酒吧里看到的21岁年轻人似乎进来时就比啤酒更习惯喝烈酒。它和苏打水或红牛混合得很好，而且更容易隐藏。
You know, you get a flask of Captain Morgan, you get the bottles, the plastic bottles, I don't know if you've seen them, they're shaped like a flask. You could put one of them in your pocket. You can't carry a case of beer in your pocket.
你知道，你有一壶摩根船长，你得到瓶子，塑料瓶，我不知道你看过没，它们形状像个扁瓶子。你可以把其中一个放在口袋里。你没法把一箱啤酒装在口袋里。
The result of more liquor and less beer, according to Ray?
根据雷的说法，更多烈酒和更少啤酒的结果？
Before, I'd say, 15 years ago, there were more people that got drunk. But now there are less people getting drunk, but of the ones that get drunk, they're a lot worse.
以前，我会说，15年前，喝醉的人更多。但现在喝醉的人更少了，但那些喝醉的人，情况要糟得多。
So Ray does see students getting what he calls "stupid drunk." But most don't do that, he says. Like a lot of the business owners I talked to, Ray likes that the students are having a good time. He likes the students, period.
所以雷确实看到学生喝到他所说的“蠢醉”。但他说是多数人不会那样。像很多我交谈过的企业主一样，雷喜欢学生们玩得开心。他喜欢学生，句号。
They're fun to be around. You know? I mean, they're all young. The energy level. You can't help but be in a good mood when you come in and everybody is-- you know, these people don't really have what I would call real problems, you know, in the real world problems, or outside the bubble that is State College.
和他们在一起很有趣。你知道吗？我是说，他们都年轻。能量水平。当你进来，看到每个人都在——你知道，这些人在现实世界中并没有什么我称之为真正的问题，或者在州立学院这个泡沫之外的问题。
You go into a bar, and people have real issues. You know, they're going through divorces, they're going through problems at work. I mean, talk to any college kid, they figure they've got their life ahead of them, they're going to make big money, they're going to change the world, they're going to do everything they want. The world hasn't kicked them in the ass yet. They haven't been beaten down, whatever you want to call it.
你走进酒吧，人们有真正的问题。你知道，他们正在经历离婚，正在经历工作中的问题。我是说，和任何大学生谈谈，他们觉得未来等着他们，他们会赚大钱，他们会改变世界，他们会做一切他们想做的事。世界还没给他们一脚。他们还没被击垮，随便你怎么叫它。
Will they get a little mouthier than they should? Sure. But I'd rather have a student that has a little bit of an edge to him than a bunch of people that hate the world, and they're just not happy.
他们会比该有的稍微嘴欠一点吗？当然。但我宁愿要一个有点锋芒的学生，也不要一群讨厌世界的人，而且他们只是不开心。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普代克。
Act Three. Talk to the Paw.
第三幕。跟爪子谈。
In 2009, the same year Penn State was ranked the number one party school in the country, the town of State College was ranked the safest metropolitan area in the country by Congressional Quarterly. Murder and other serious crimes are almost nonexistent.
2009年，也就是宾州立大学被评为全国第一派对学校的同一年，州立学院镇被国会季刊评为全国最安全的大都市区。谋杀和其他严重犯罪几乎不存在。
But as you've heard, of course, that doesn't mean that the streets are quiet. There's so much activity that 47% of the town's budget go into police services, which is high for a town this size. On the Saturday night that we were in town, 24 officers were on duty patrolling in cars, on bikes, on foot. And that's just to cover the town. The University has its own police force patrolling the campus. One of our producers, Aaron Scott, rode along with one of the town's officers for the night shift.
但正如你所听到的，当然，这并不意味着街道很安静。有太多的活动，镇预算的47%用于警察服务，对于这个规模的城镇来说很高。在我们镇上的那个周六晚上，24名警察在值班，在车里、自行车上、步行巡逻。这仅仅是为了覆盖城镇。大学有自己的警察部队巡逻校园。我们的制片人之一亚伦·斯科特和一个镇警察一起上了夜班。
Officer Martin Hanes tells me the job's all about repetition. From 10 to 12, students start flooding the streets. From 12 to 2, he deals with loud parties, fake IDs, and underage drinking.
马丁·海恩斯警官告诉我，工作全是重复。从10点到12点，学生开始涌入街道。从12点到2点，他处理吵闹的派对、假ID和未成年饮酒。
2 to 3 is usually when you get a lot of the DUIs, because the bars have just closed, and a lot more fights. Then 3 on is, I always say it's our victim hour. It's when we go to the hospital, a lot of times. And usually at 4 after is when get our drunk kid in the house.
2点到3点通常是你得到很多酒驾的时候，因为酒吧刚关门，打架也更多。然后3点以后是，我总是说这是我们的受害者时刻。通常是我们去医院的时候。通常在4点以后是我们把醉酒孩子带回家的时候。
Drunk kid in the house. That's what you heard about earlier on the show, where some drunken student stumbles into, if not breaks into, a stranger's house.
带醉酒孩子回家。那就是你之前在节目里听到的，有些醉酒学生跌跌撞撞走进，甚至闯入陌生人的房子。
Center county 30 to 61.
中心县30到61。
Arrest for public drunkenness and underage drinking have increased 5% this fall. Officer Hanes blames the number one party school ranking, at least in part. Students see it as a national title they have to defend.
今年秋天，因公共醉酒和未成年饮酒被捕的案件增加了5%。海恩斯警官部分将责任归咎于第一派对学校的排名。学生们认为这是一个他们必须捍卫的国家头衔。
People are proud, like sports teams are proud. We're number one. The number one drinking school. Let's show them what it's like.
人们很自豪，就像运动队很自豪一样。我们是第一。第一饮酒学校。让我们给他们看看这是什么样。
So it's 12:30, and the bouncer outside Indigo, the town's biggest dance club, flags us down. He says a guy tried to pass off a license that wasn't his, and then fled into a hotel two doors down.
现在是12点30分，镇上最大舞蹈俱乐部Indigo外面的保安把我们拦下。他说有个家伙试图出示一张不是他的执照，然后逃进了两个门外的酒店。
As soon as you pulled up, he took off.
你一停车，他就跑了。
The bouncer leads us into the hotel and up the stairs to a bar. He checks the bathroom and says the guy's inside. We all go in and find him standing alone at a urinal.
保安带着我们进酒店上楼到一个酒吧。他检查了洗手间说那家伙在里面。我们都进去发现他独自站在小便池前。
You have ID on you? Why are you trying to pass off somebody else's ID?
你有ID吗？为什么试图冒用别人的ID？
Sir, I have one ID on me.
长官，我身上有一张ID。
You saying this gentleman's lying?
你是说这位先生在撒谎？
Yeah. I have one-- I have two IDs.
对。我有一——我有两张ID。
All right. Do me a favor. Put your hands behind your back. We're going to place you under arrest, OK?
好了。帮我个忙。把手放到背后。我们要把你逮捕，好吗？
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
I'm dead serious.
我是说真的。
Officer Hanes is generally pretty nice to the students, but because the kid ran and is now lying, he switched over to hardass cop.
海恩斯警官对学生通常很友善，但因为这孩子跑了还在撒谎，他变成了强硬警察。
OK, let's go.
好了，走吧。
OK. For what reason?
好。因为什么？
Presenting a fake ID.
提供假ID。
Sir, I don't have a fake ID.
长官，我没假ID。
Now you're lying to me.
现在你在对我撒谎。
Officer Hanes takes him out of the hotel and puts him in the car. Then, because the cop car sometimes riles up the crowd in front of the club, Officer Hanes drives down the block and pulls into a parking lot to write up the guy. I'll call them Nick. He's skinny, clean cut, and despite his initial denial, he caves quickly and cooperates.
海恩斯警官把他带出酒店放进车里。然后，因为警车有时会激怒俱乐部前的人群，海恩斯警官开车沿街开进停车场写那家伙的单子。我叫他尼克。他瘦瘦的，干净利落，尽管最初否认，但他很快就崩溃并配合了。
You're not a student at all?
你根本不是学生吗？
No. I'm visiting my cousin.
不。我来看我表弟。
You've visiting your cousin? Where's he at?
来看你表弟？他在哪儿？
She is out and about.
她出去了。
In the middle of writing the citation, Officer Hanes looks up and stops.
在写传票的过程中，海恩斯警官抬头停了下来。
That guy right there? Wait a second.
那个家伙？等一下。
A guy in a hoodie just walked into a parking lot on the other side of the alley.
一个穿着连帽衫的家伙刚走进巷子另一边的停车场。
To your right here, in about two seconds, someone's going to be peeing in public.
你右边这里，大约两秒钟后，有人要在公共场所撒尿。
Officer Hanes has been at this for three and a half years. He knows where the drunk kids go to pee, where they'll run if they think he's chasing them, the tricks they'll use to hide their open containers. He's like a biologist who's catalogued this species' full range of behavior. And it's an oddly biological job. His arrests revolve around alcohol going into the body, alcohol's effects on the body, and the resulting liquids coming out.
海恩斯警官做这个已经三年半了。他知道醉酒孩子去哪儿撒尿，如果他们认为他在追他们会往哪儿跑，他们用来隐藏露天酒瓶的技巧。他就像一个记录了这个物种完整行为范围的生物学家。这是一个奇怪的生物学工作。他的逮捕围绕着酒精进入身体、酒精对身体的影响，以及产生的液体流出。
With Nick in the back of the car, we drive down the alley and pull into a parking lot on the other side. In the back corner is a large green generator.
尼克在车后座，我们开车沿巷子开到另一边的停车场。后角有一个大的绿色发电机。
He's behind the generator.
他在发电机后面。
We get out of the car and sure enough, as we approach, a splashing sound. And then Officer Hanes pulls a hunched student from behind the generator. He tells the public urinator to sit by the wall while he returns to the car to finish Nick's paperwork.
我们下车，果不其然，当我们接近时，一阵泼溅声。然后海恩斯警官从发电机后面拉出一个弓着腰的学生。他让公共排尿者坐在墙边，同时他回到车里完成尼克的文书工作。
Since Nick is only one month shy of 21 and cooperative, Officer Hanes says he'll change the charge to disorderly conduct, which means Nick won't lose his license, but will still have to pay a fine.
因为尼克距离21岁只有一个多月且配合，海恩斯警官说他会把指控改为扰乱治安，这意味着尼克不会失去执照，但仍需支付罚款。
Do you know how much the fine will be, or no?
你知道罚款是多少吗，还是不知道？
It's set by the judge, but it's between $25 to $300.
法官定的，但介于25到300美元之间。
Can you put any input in there?
你能在那儿提点建议吗？
I can.
我可以。
Would you like to throw a 25 only?
你愿意只提25吗？
Well, that's going to have to take place at the court.
好吧，那得在法庭上发生。
I'm on a budget.
我预算有限。
All right, man.
好了，伙计。
Can I get that ID back?
我能拿回那个ID吗？
No, you can't.
不，你不能。
As Nick leaves, he tries to shake hands.
当尼克离开时，他试图握手。
Thank you very much, sir.
非常感谢，长官。
I know. Take it easy, all right? Did you use the bathroom up there and did you wash your hands?
我知道。放轻松，好吗？你在那儿用洗手间了吗，你洗手了吗？
Of course I washed my hands. Of course I was faking going to pee. Sorry about that.
我当然洗手了。我当然是在假装去撒尿。对此很抱歉。
Hanes tells me avoiding questionable handshakes is a regular hazard of the job. The public urinator also offered his.
海恩斯告诉我避免可疑的握手是这份工作经常的风险。那个公共排尿者也提出了握手。
Sorry, but if you were just caught urinating, I'm not shaking your hands.
抱歉，但如果你刚才被抓到排尿，我不会和你握手的。
I think I scared him enough that he splashed himself, and probably splashed his hand.
我觉得我把他吓坏了，以至于他溅到了自己，可能还溅到了自己的手。
There's a bottle of Purell in the driver's door compartment. But not everyone deals with is so civil. Maybe it's because they're drunk. But you know that deferential respect and anxiety most people feel when dealing with cops? That gets chucked out the window more than you think.
驾驶员门侧格里有一瓶Purell。但并非每个人处理起来都那么文明。可能是因为他们喝醉了。但你知道大多数人在面对警察时感到的那种恭敬的尊重和焦虑吗？这被抛到窗外的次数比你想象的要多。
A few months back, Officer Hanes was pulling out of a parking deck to answer a call when three girls stopped him, waving their arms and screaming for help.
几个月前，海恩斯警官正从一个停车平台开出来去应答一个电话时，三个女孩拦住了他，挥舞着手臂尖叫着求救。
And I said, do you need help or something? Is anything going on? They said, we need a ride. Can you give us a ride? I said, no, I'm not a taxi. I can't give you a ride. You need to call a taxicab. And they started yelling at me, you know, Why can't you give me a ride? Quite being a, you know, a-hole and all that. And then one girl started climbing in through the window. So I yelled at her to get out of car or she was going to be arrested, she got mad and she went to the back of my car when I started pulling in. I heard a loud thump. She punched me around the side. I got out of the car, and she started trying to run away, and her two friends got in front of me and started pushing me back, telling her to run.
我说，你们需要帮助或什么吗？发生什么事了吗？她们说，我们需要搭车。你能带我们一程吗？我说，不，我不是出租车。我不能带你们。你们需要打出租车。她们开始对我大喊，你知道，为什么要这么刻薄之类的。然后一个女孩开始从窗户爬进来。所以我对她大喊让她下车否则就会被捕，她生气了，当我开始发动时她去了我的车后。我听到一声巨响。她打了我车的一边。我下了车，她开始试图逃跑，她的两个朋友挡在我前面推我，告诉她快跑。
Center county, 3261. 10-8.
中心县，3261。10-8。
By 4 AM, the streets are empty. All in all, State College police issued 80 citations this weekend, including 17 for underage drinking. Not many, if you consider there were tens of thousands of underaged students drinking at Penn State. Officer Hanes told me he only goes after underage drinkers if they give them a reason, like fighting, carrying an open container, or being just sloppy drunk.
到了凌晨4点，街道空无一人。总而言之，州立学院警方这个周末发出了80张传票，包括17张未成年饮酒。并不多，如果你考虑到有成千上万名未成年学生在宾州立大学喝酒。海恩斯警官告诉我，他只在未成年饮酒者给出理由时才去抓他们，比如打架、携带露天酒瓶或只是醉得一塌糊涂。
For a football weekend, it was pretty slow, which Officer Hanes chalks up to the team's relatively poor showing this fall. His job ebbs and flows with the success of the Nittany Lion, which puts him, as an alum and a fan, in an awkward position. He used to root for national championship. Now he prefers a one-loss team. He says it keeps the streets quieter.
对于一个橄榄球周末，这相当慢，海恩斯警官将其归咎于球队今年秋天相对较差的表现。他的工作随着尼塔尼雄狮队的成功而起伏，这作为一名校友和球迷，让他处于一个尴尬的位置。他过去支持全国冠军。现在他更喜欢输一场的球队。他说这让街道更安静。
Aaron Scott.
亚伦·斯科特。
Act Four. A Drinking School With A Football Problem.
第四幕。一所有橄榄球问题的饮酒学校。
The big reason anybody worries about all the drinking at Penn State, of course, is it's dangerous. Every year, 1,700 college students across the country die of alcohol-related injuries. The average amount of alcohol in college students' blood when they come into the local emergency room in State College is steadily rising each year. It's now at 0.252, three times the legal limit at which you can drive a car. The head of the emergency department told me that it's a level that normal drinkers can't even usually get to because they'd throw up, fall asleep first.
任何人担心宾州立大学的所有饮酒问题的最大原因，当然，是它很危险。每年，全国有1700名大学生死于酒精相关的伤害。州立学院当地急诊室的学生血中酒精含量每年都在稳步上升。现在是0.252，是你驾驶汽车合法限额的三倍。急诊科主任告诉我，这是一个普通饮酒者通常甚至无法达到的水平，因为他们会先呕吐、睡着。
What's interesting, if you ask Penn State administrators about what they're doing to deal with all the student drinking, they're not defensive. I met the head of University Relations with the school, the guy who's responsible for making the school look good to the public, and he was right upfront about it. Yeah, he said, drinking is a terrible problem, and we have tried everything we can think of to fix it, twice.
有趣的是，如果你问宾州立大学的管理人员他们在做什么来处理所有学生饮酒问题，他们并不防卫。我见了学校主管大学关系的负责人，那个负责让学校在公众面前看起来很好的人，他直言不讳。是的，他说，饮酒是个可怕的问题，我们已经尝试了所有我们能想到的办法来解决它，两次。
Which is actually more or less true. The school has spent millions attacking this problem. They've tried to teach the students, in all kinds of ways, about safer drinking. They created alcohol-free halls and dorms, they created a task force, there have been town-gown commissions, they've mounted a huge program of alcohol-free late night activities. The weekend we were there, that included comedian Patton Oswalt for free for students, free movies, a Halo tournament.
这实际上或多或少是事实。学校花了数百万来攻击这个问题。他们试图通过各种方式教育学生关于更安全饮酒的知识。他们创建了无酒精大厅和宿舍，他们创建了一个特别工作组，有了城镇与大学的委员会，他们安装了一个巨大的无酒精深夜活动计划。我们在那里的那个周末，包括为学生免费提供的喜剧演员巴顿·奥斯瓦尔特、免费电影、光环锦标赛。
Obviously this hadn't gotten the job done. Sarah Koenig explains why this problem is just so hard for university administrators to fix.
显然这没能完成任务。莎拉·凯尼格解释了为什么这个问题对大学管理人员来说如此难以解决。
The first university president in the country to take on excessive drinking in a very public way was Graham Spanier when he arrived at Penn State 15 years ago. At a time when most schools didn't want to talk about it, he was relentless. Here he is in his 1998 State of the University speech.
全国第一个以非常公开的方式处理过量饮酒的大学校长是格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔，15年前他来到宾州立大学。在大多数学校不想谈论这个问题的时候，他是不懈的。这是他在1998年大学状况演讲中的片段。
To put it succinctly, let me say to all high school students. If you are interested in Penn State because of the attraction of binge drinking, please go somewhere else.
简而言之，让我对所有高中生说。如果你因为酗酒的吸引力而对宾州立大学感兴趣，请去别的地方。
The message didn't always go down well. A month after this speech, Spanier was booed by students at a football game. A local bar ran an ad depicting him as Hitler, speaking with a German accent and sending storm troopers to raid a fraternity. He got pushback from alumni, a University trustee, even the local ACLU, who all said this wasn't an issue for a university president.
这个信息并不总是那么好接受。在那次演讲一个月后，斯帕尼尔在橄榄球比赛中被学生嘘了。一家当地酒吧做了一则广告，将他描绘成希特勒，说着德语口音，并派遣冲锋队突袭兄弟会。他受到了校友、大学受托人，甚至当地公民自由联盟的抵制，他们都说这不是大学校长该管的问题。
After 1998, he stopped hammering the topic so publicly, he says, in favor of working on it more behind the scenes. Ask the people behind the scenes today how it's going, and they'll tell you they're losing ground.
1998年之后，他停止在公开场合谈论这个话题，他说，倾向于在幕后解决它。今天问问幕后的人进展如何，他们会告诉你他们正在失去阵地。
Linda Lasalle is the administrator in charge of educating Penn State students about the dangers of alcohol. Some of her work happens in the classroom.
琳达·拉萨尔是负责教育宾州立大学学生关于酒精危险的管理人员。她的一些工作在课堂上进行。
And I talk about how our data shows that most of our students actually have five or fewer when they drink. Or we had data they showed that a few years back. And students would laugh at me! They would say, oh, you know, none of my friends drink that little. We're all drinking eight, nine, ten. So this higher level of consumption to them is the norm.
我谈到我们的数据如何显示我们大多数学生在喝酒时实际上喝五杯或更少。或者我们几年前有数据显示。学生们会嘲笑我！他们会说，噢，你知道，我的朋友没几个喝那么少的。我们都在喝八、九、十杯。所以这种更高水平的消费对他们来说是常态。
For ten years, Linda Lasalle's office has taught kids about blood alcohol levels and alcohol poisoning. They administer a mandatory online alcohol education program for incoming freshman called AlcoholEdu. They did a social norms media campaign aimed at changing students' behavior by teaching them that most students drink less than they think. Lasalle heard the plastic drinking cups they handed out became popular for beer pong.
十年来，琳达·拉萨尔的办公室教孩子们关于血液酒精水平和酒精中毒的知识。他们为大一新生管理一个强制性的在线酒精教育项目，叫AlcoholEdu。他们做了一项社会规范媒体运动，旨在通过教导学生大多数学生喝得比他们想象的少来改变学生的行为。拉萨尔听说他们发放的塑料饮酒杯成了啤酒乒乓球的热门用具。
No real success. We're seeing some tremendous knowledge gains from students who participate in the program. Our preliminary data shows that there's no significant behavior change, however.
没取得真正的成功。我们看到参与该项目的学生知识水平有了巨大提升。然而，我们的初步数据显示，行为没有显著改变。
So armed with all these facts about what alcohol can do to you, students here seem to drink just as much as they always did.
所以带着所有关于酒精能对你做什么的事实，这里的学生似乎喝得和以前一样多。
It's just, it must feel so defeating.
只是，这一定感觉太让人受挫了。
It does. It feels very defeating. I have very conflicting feelings about it. Because I feel like there's not very much we can do, that there are so many things that contribute to this problem that are out of our control. And you know, at the same time, I also feel like I want to be able to do something. No college student should ever die because they simply had too much to drink.
确实。感觉非常受挫。我对此有非常冲突的感觉。因为我觉得我们能做的不多，因为有太多导致这个问题的因素是我们无法控制的。而且你知道，与此同时，我也觉得我想能做点什么。没有任何大学生应该仅仅因为喝太多而死。
So I guess I don't have a good answer. I don't know what would really make a difference, especially in this campus.
所以我猜我没有好的答案。我不知道什么真的会带来不同，尤其是在这个校园里。
Is that hard for you to say, as someone who has your job?
作为一个做这份工作的人，说这话很难吗？
Yeah. It's very difficult to say.
是的。非常难说。
This worst case scenario, a student dying, was on everyone's mind this fall, because it happened in September, just a month after school started. Maintenance workers found the body of Joe Dado at the bottom of an outdoor stairwell. Dado had been missing for a couple of days after he left a frat party alone at 3:30 in the morning. It seems he'd been climbing on top of a wall between two classroom buildings and fallen on his head. He was a freshman, just 18 years old.
这个最坏的情况，学生死亡，今年秋天每个人都在想，因为它发生在九月，学校开学仅仅一个月。维修工人在室外楼梯间底部发现了乔·达多的尸体。达多在凌晨3点半独自离开兄弟会派对后失踪了几天。看来他在两栋教学楼之间的一堵墙上爬，头朝下摔了下去。他是个新生，才18岁。
At other schools, the administration has sometimes used these sorts of deaths to push for change. In 2004, after a 19 year old sophomore at Colorado State named Samantha Spady was found dead of alcohol poisoning at the Sigma Pi frat house. The frat house was shut down, and all other fraternities banned alcohol. Alcohol sales were banned inside the football stadium, and her parents started a foundation in her name. MIT, Indiana University, University of Virginia all reacted with sweeping changes after alcohol deaths.
在其他学校，管理层有时利用这些死亡事件来推动变革。2004年，在科罗拉多州立大学一名19岁大二学生萨曼莎·斯派迪被发现死于西格玛派兄弟会的酒精中毒后。兄弟会被关闭，所有其他兄弟会禁止酒精。橄榄球场内禁止销售酒精，她的父母以她的名字成立了一个基金会。麻省理工学院、印第安纳大学、弗吉尼亚大学在酒精死亡事件后都做出了全面的改变。
Here, the immediate reaction to Dado's death from senior administration was remarkable for its gentleness. Nobody hollered at the students to quit drinking so much. Rather, the message was, if you're going to get plastered, do it more responsibility. Graham Spanier issued a statement telling students to, quote, "Remember our commitment to one another's safety." Damon Simms, vice president of Student Affairs, told students at a meeting that he hoped the entire student body would double their efforts in watching out for each other.
在这里，高层管理对达多死亡的直接反应因其温柔而引人注目。没有人对学生咆哮让他们戒酒。相反，信息是，如果你要喝到烂醉，要更负责任地做。格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔发表声明告诉学生，引用，“记住我们对彼此安全的承诺。”学生事务副校长达蒙·西姆斯在一次会议上告诉学生，他希望整个学生群体能加倍努力互相照看。
Maybe they figured this message had a better chance of sticking, and it did stick. The lesson students have taken is not that Dado drank too much, but that he would be alive today if only he hadn't been alone.
也许他们认为这个信息坚持下去的机会更大，而且确实坚持下去了。学生们学到的教训不是达多喝太多，而是如果他不一个人待着，他今天还活着。
My colleague Lisa Pollak talked to freshmen at the student union here.
我的同事丽莎·波拉克采访了这里的学生会新生。
We've become more responsible. Nobody goes home alone anymore. We call each other, make sure we're doing OK.
我们变得更负责任了。没人再独自回家了。我们互相打电话，确保我们都还好。
My friends, we all try to stay together a lot more, and don't leave anybody out by themselves late at night. Like even if they say they're fine, you're like, no. You're not fine.
我的朋友们，我们都尽量多待在一起，不把任何人单独留在深夜。即使他们说他们很好，你也会说，不。你不好。
OK. This might sound like a really silly question, but did any of you think to say, well, why don't we just not drink anymore?
好。这听起来可能是一个非常愚蠢的问题，但你们中有人想过说，好吧，我们为什么不干脆不喝酒了？
No, we didn't say that. But yeah.
不，我们没这么说。但是的。
It seems to be the perennial lesson of these accidents. After a drunk girl fell from a sixth story window in 1997, this was the story in the local newspaper. Quote, "The death of a Penn State student at a party a week ago may prompt partygoers to keep a closer eye on each other's safety, students say. But, they add, the accident probably won't change their drinking behavior." Penn state students also fell to their deaths in 1993, 1987, 1984, 1983.
这些事故似乎是永恒的教训。在1997年一个醉酒女孩从六楼窗户掉下去后，这是当地报纸上的报道。引用，“宾州立大学一名学生在一周前的派对上死亡可能会促使派对参与者更加密切地关注彼此的安全，学生们说。但是，他们补充说，这次事故可能不会改变他们的饮酒行为。”宾州立大学学生还在1993年、1987年、1984年、1983年跌落死亡。
The averageness of what killed freshman Joe Dado is exactly why this is such a challenge for administrators. To Penn State students, the amount Dado drank that night is completely normal. After questioning his friends, police reported that Dado drank several shots of vodka and mixed drinks in his dorm, the whole pregaming thing, and then got on the shuttle bus with his friends. They went to a frat called ATO, played beer pong, drank four or five cans of Natural Light each. Then they went to Fiji, another frat, where Dado did a couple shots of whiskey. By the end of it, his blood alcohol level was high, but not crazy high. It was a third less than the average for kids brought to the emergency room for alcohol.
乔·达多死于平凡的事件恰恰就是为什么这对管理人员来说是一个巨大的挑战。对宾州立大学学生来说，达多那天晚上的饮酒量是完全正常的。在询问他的朋友后，警方报告说达多在他的宿舍里喝了几杯伏特加和预调酒，整个预热过程，然后和他的朋友坐穿梭巴士。他们去了个叫ATO的兄弟会，玩啤酒乒乓球，每人喝了四五罐天然淡啤。然后他们去了Fiji，另一个兄弟会，达多喝了几杯威士忌。结束时，他的血液酒精水平很高，但不是疯狂的高。这比被送到急诊室因酒精的孩子平均水平低了三分之一。
It was just a normal night. It wasn't like overindulgence. It wasn't like a ridiculous, wild party.
这只是正常的一晚。它不像过度放纵。不像一个荒谬、疯狂的派对。
The last person to talk to Dado that night was Jack Townsend, a 21 year old junior. He gave Dado those shots of whiskey at Fiji, and he's been criminally charged with providing alcohol to a minor, along with the frat.
那天晚上最后一个和达多说话的人是杰克·汤森德，一个21岁的大三学生。他在Fiji给了达多那些威士忌，他和兄弟会一起被刑事指控提供酒精给未成年人。
Townsend was a friend of Dado's. He played soccer with him in high school. He took one of his sisters to the prom. He told producer Lisa Pollak that when he looks back at that night, it's hard for them to reconcile that something so ordinary led to something so terrible.
汤森德是达多的朋友。他在高中和他一起踢足球。他带了他的一个姐妹参加舞会。他告诉制片人丽莎·波拉克，当他回顾那个晚上时，对他来说很难调和如此平凡的事情导致了如此可怕的结果。
So I thought, you know, nothing of it that night. You know, it's just a friendly drink. Based on the things I heard from the entire timeline of that night, I mean, it reminded me of my freshman days. The same thing, you know?
所以我认为，你知道，那天晚上没什么。你知道，这只是一个友好的酒。基于我从那一晚整个时间线听到的事情，我是说，它提醒了我大一的时光。一样的事情，你知道？
And that you drank even before you go out?
而且你在出门前就喝了？
Yeah, yeah. I mean, none of that was shocking to me. None of that was really surprising to me. It was typical weekend night for a freshman. I have thought about how, like, how didn't I realize how dangerous some of this stuff could have been before it happened.
对，对。我是说，那些对我来说都不震惊。那些对我来说真的都不惊讶。这对新生来说是典型的一个周末晚上。我曾想过，像，我怎么没意识到其中一些东西在发生之前有多危险。
Because it hadn't really struck you before?
因为这之前没真正打击到你？
Yeah. Because nothing ever really bad ever came from it until now.
对。因为直到现在从来没真正发生过什么坏事。
Joe Dado's case fits neatly into a variety of depressing data sets. Researchers know, for instance, that the bingiest of the binge drinkers are white male freshmen, and even if he wasn't binging, there's the fact that most bad things happened early on in the school year. The alcohol ER admissions here for September are much higher than for the rest of the year, for instance. He drank Vladimir vodka that night, the most widely sold liquor in State College, and was hanging out with fraternity members, who tend to drink more than non-Greek students.
乔·达多的案例完美地融入了各种令人沮丧的数据集。例如，研究人员知道，酗酒者中的酗酒者是白人男性新生，即使他不是酗酒，还有坏事大部分发生在学年初期。例如，9月份的酒精急诊入院人数远高于一年中的其他时间。那天晚上他喝了弗拉基米尔伏特加，州立学院最广泛销售的烈酒，而且他和兄弟会成员在一起，他们倾向于比非希腊组织学生喝得更多。
Bob Saltz, a senior research scientist at the Pacific Institute for Research and Evaluation, says here's what's counterintuitive about managing drinking on college campuses and why so few are having success. He says that while your heaviest drinkers are of course at the highest risk of getting hurt or hurting somebody else, there aren't that many of them. So you really also need to be worrying about the light and moderate drinkers, who vastly outnumber the heavy drinkers. Kids like Joe Dado, who might only overdo it once in a while.
太平洋研究所评估的高级研究科学家鲍勃·萨尔茨说，关于管理大学校园饮酒的违反直觉的事实是这样的，而且为什么几乎没有人取得成功。他说，虽然你的酗酒者当然是受伤或伤害别人风险最高的，但他们并不多。所以你确实还需要担心轻度和中度饮酒者，他们的人数远远多于酗酒者。像乔·达多这样的孩子，可能只是偶尔过量。
Even though at any given time, most of the students are going to have an easy time of it, no one's going to get hurt, we just don't know who it is who's going to get hurt over a large population. But the concern many administrators have, and some students as well, is that it seems somehow wrong to impose a strategy that's universal, because again, the holdover concept that we really should be only focusing on the heaviest drinkers.
尽管在任何给定时间，大多数学生都能轻松应付，没人会受伤，我们只是不知道在一个庞大的人口中谁会受伤。但许多管理人员，以及一些学生担心的，是强加一个普遍的策略看起来似乎在某种程度上是错误的，因为再次强调，那种我们真的应该只关注酗酒者的概念。
Saltz's strategy for reducing risk to the biggest population of students is so simple that I missed it the first time he said it. You reduce risk by limiting kids' access to alcohol. The less alcohol is available, the less kids drink. The less they drink, the fewer bad things happen. In practice, what this means is a police crackdown, and just as importantly, the perception of one.
萨尔茨为减少最大学生群体的风险而制定的减少策略如此简单，以至于他第一次说时我错过了。你通过限制孩子们接触酒精来降低风险。酒精越少，孩子们喝得越少。喝得越少，坏事发生得越少。在实践中，这意味着警察的严厉打击，同样重要的是，这种感知的打击。
The problem with this strategy has been that there was hardly any campus-wide research to back it up, until now. Saltz is about to publish the results of an NIH-funded study he did at 14 California campuses. At half of them, cops went on party patrols, broke up large off-campus parties. They stepped up DUI enforcement and enforced laws against sales to minors at bars. And most important, they heavily publicized this stepped-up enforcement to students so they would start self-policing, rather than risk getting busted.
这个策略的问题在于几乎没有校园范围的研究来支持它，直到现在。萨尔茨即将发布他在14个加州校园做的NIH资助研究结果。在一半校园里，警察进行派对巡逻，解散大型校外派对。他们加强了酒驾执法，并执行了禁止向酒吧未成年人销售的法律。最重要的是，他们大力向学生宣传这种加强的执法，以便他们开始自我监管，而不是冒被抓的风险。
By the end of the study, Saltz found that fewer kids were getting drunk. The campuses where they cracked down reported 6,000 fewer drunk students coming from off-campus parties, and 4,000 fewer coming from bars.
研究结束时，萨尔茨发现更少的孩子在喝醉。加强打击的校园报告了6000名从校外派对出来的醉酒学生减少，4000名从酒吧出来的减少。
And we were able to show that increased controls on off-campus drinking did not lead to any displacement of those problems somewhere else, which is what people assume, is that if you do a better job at off-campus parties, that students will just go to a park, or back to the dorms, or some other place, and that the level of problems will stay the same. And I was happy to see that that did not happen in our case.
我们能够证明加强对校外饮酒的控制并没有导致这些问题转移到其他地方，这是人们所假设的，就是如果你在校外派对上做得更好，学生就会去公园，或者回到宿舍，或者其他什么地方，而问题的水平会保持不变。我很高兴看到在我们案例中没有发生这种情况。
Saltz says sprawling university bureaucracies usually aren't well-suited to this kind of tough guy strategy. For one thing, they're run by educators, who tend to think they can simply teach kids to drink less. But when I asked him if there's any university out there that's having real, on-the-ground, sustained success, he immediately says yes. University of Nebraska-Lincoln. Their drinking reduction stats are the envy of the student affairs world.
萨尔茨说，庞大的大学官僚机构通常不适合这种强硬的策略。首先，它们由教育工作者管理，他们倾向于认为他们可以简单地教育孩子少喝。但当我问他是否有任何大学正在取得真正的、地面上的、持续的成功时，他立即说是的。内布拉斯加大学林肯分校。他们的饮酒减少数据是学生事务界的羡慕对象。
Starting in 1998, the school teamed up with the city of Lincoln and declared an all-out war on out of control drinking-- a data-driven, goal-oriented war. Not only did they do the kind of police crackdown Saltz advocates, they attacked the problem from every possible angle, enlisting of bar owners, state legislators, liberal arts students, business students, high school principals. They lobbied to digitize Nebraska's driver's license to stop rampant fake IDs. They tried to knock down the average number of drinks on a student's 21st birthday from 14 to 7.
从1998年开始，学校与林肯市合作，宣布对失控饮酒进行全面战争——一场数据驱动、目标明确的战争。他们不仅进行了萨尔茨所倡导的警察严厉打击，他们还从每一个可能的角度攻击这个问题，招募酒吧老板、州议员、文科学生、商学院学生、高中校长。他们游说将内布拉斯加州的驾照数字化，以制止猖獗的假ID。他们试图将学生21岁生日的平均饮酒量从14杯降到7杯。
Linda Major, Assistant to the Vice Chancellor at UNL, was the general in this war from the beginning. She says breaking up wild parties in residential neighborhoods was one of the most controversial things they did early on. Also, one of the most effective.
琳达·梅杰，内布拉斯加大学林肯分校副校长的助理，从一开始就是这场战争的将军。她说在住宅区解散狂野派对是他们早期做的最具争议的事情之一。也是最有效的事情之一。
And over the course of time, the wild party patrol really went out very few weekends, but people believed that it could happen any weekend, and so behavior was naturally curbed.
随着时间的推移，狂野派对巡逻队真的很少在周末出去，但人们相信它可能在任何周末发生，所以行为被自然抑制了。
Major sensed the place felt different, and every statistical indicator backed up that feeling. There were far fewer neighbor complaints about parties. Students reported studying more, getting more sleep. Fewer people dropped out, and there were fewer reports of unwanted sex or driving drunk. Way more freshmen were abstaining from alcohol. And binge drinking numbers sank from 63% of students in 1997 down to 42% in 2007.
梅杰感觉到这个地方感觉不同了，每一个统计指标都支持那种感觉。关于派对的邻居投诉少得多了。学生们报告说学习更多，睡眠更多。退学的人少了，关于不想要的性行为或酒驾的报道也少了。放弃酒精的新生多了很多。酗酒人数从1997年学生的63%下降到2007年的42%。
The frustration for Penn State is that it follows the same research as UNL, and does a lot of the same things. It has as many alcohol programs and interventions as any university in the country.
宾州立大学的挫败感在于它遵循与内布拉斯加大学林肯分校相同的研究，并做了很多同样的事情。它拥有和全国任何大学一样多的酒精计划和干预措施。
But one researcher told me that the problem is almost no colleges, Penn State included, properly evaluate what they're doing, so they really don't know what works and what doesn't. This work is tricky. There's so many variables that just because something works at one school doesn't mean it'll work the same way someplace else.
但一位研究人员告诉我，问题是几乎没有任何大学，包括宾州立大学，适当地评估他们所做的事情，所以他们真的不知道什么有效，什么无效。这项工作很棘手。有太多的变量，只是因为某件事在一所学校有效，并不意味着它会在其他地方以同样的方式起作用。
Still, it's clear Penn State has not done what UNL did-- joined with the town and declared total war. At least not recently. There's no shortage of complaints about the university's efforts. Why won't it ban alcohol from the dorms, or take on the widespread underage drinking, or punish students more harshly, expel them, even, when they break the law?
尽管如此，显而易见宾州立大学没有做内布拉斯加大学林肯分校做的事——与城镇联合并宣布全面战争。至少最近没有。关于学校努力的投诉不计其数。为什么它不禁止宿舍里的酒精，或解决猖獗的未成年饮酒，或在他们违法时更严厉地惩罚学生，甚至开除他们？
We need to do things differently. Everything that once upon a time was not open to reconsideration needs to be open to reconsideration.
我们需要以不同的方式做事。所有曾经不接受重新考虑的事情都需要接受重新考虑。
Luckily, the one person at Penn State agitating for a complete overhaul of the University's drinking reduction strategy happens to be the guy in charge of them-- Damon Simms. He's the new vice president for Student Affairs, and he's not messing around. When he rattled off a list of recent meetings he's had on the topic, it was almost comical in its scope. The town manager, the editor of the local newspaper, the borough council, student government, town and university police, faculty, fraternity leaders, on and on.
幸运的是，宾州立大学那位致力于彻底改革学校减少饮酒策略的人恰好是负责他们的人——达蒙·西姆斯。他是学生事务的新任副校长，他不是在闹着玩。当他列出一系列他最近就这个主题进行的会议时，其范围几乎是滑稽的。镇经理、当地报纸编辑、区议会、学生政府、城镇和大学警察、教职员工、兄弟会领袖，等等。
Simms thinks being named number one party school and the death of Joe Dado have pushed the issue to some kind of tipping point, and he plans to capitalize on it. He's working on a list of ideas. When we met, it was 72 items long.
西姆斯认为被命名为第一派对学校和乔·达多的死亡已经把这个问题推向了某种临界点，他计划利用它。他正在列出一份想法清单。我们见面时，它有72项长。
And there are some sacred cows that need to be reconsidered, too.
而且还有一些需要重新考虑的圣牛。
He says that includes grade inflation, troublesome fraternities, and out-of-control tailgating. Simms will be proposing a bunch of new initiatives early next September, including new sanctions for students who break alcohol laws.
他说这包括成绩通胀、麻烦的兄弟会和失控的汽车后备箱派对。西姆斯将在明年9月初提议一系列新倡议，包括对违反酒精法律的学生的新制裁。
Already fraternities have new rules. No more Wednesday night parties. On other nights, photo ID required for entry, and professional bouncers at the door.
兄弟会已经有了新规则。没有周三晚上的派对了。在其他夜晚，进入需要带照片的ID，门口有专业保安。
But what you hear all the time around here, off the record, from local residents, from faculty, from other administrators, is that Spanier really can't, or won't, do anything more draconian about the drinking problem here. Make fraternities dry, say, or curb tailgating. Because politically, he simply cannot risk alienating those secret cows Simms is talking about. Especially alumni and athletics, meaning football, which brings in enormous money.
但你一直在这里听到的，非正式的，来自当地居民、教职员工、其他管理人员的是，斯帕尼尔真的不能，或不会，采取任何更严厉的措施来解决这里的饮酒问题。比如说，让兄弟会禁酒，或抑制汽车后备箱派对。因为在政治上，他根本不能冒失去西姆斯所说的那些圣牛的风险。尤其是校友和体育，意味着橄榄球，它带来了巨大的钱。
Tens of thousands of alumni come to football games, rent skyboxes-- the only places in the stadium where you can drink, by the way. They arrange their lives around the season. It's a big part of why they give money to the school. Last year, alums and other donors gave $182 million.
成千上万的校友来橄榄球比赛，租包厢——顺便说一句，这是体育场里唯一可以喝酒的地方。他们围绕赛季安排生活。这是他们给学校捐钱的重要原因之一。去年，校友和其他捐赠者捐了1.82亿美元。
I asked Spanier if there was something he needed to be careful about here in terms of the connection between football and donors and booze.
我问斯帕尼尔，在橄榄球、捐赠者和酒之间的联系方面，他是否需要小心什么。
No. I don't buy that at all. That's just speculation that you hear from people like, oh, that must be part of the issue. They would never go after the alumni. The fact is, what happens with six or seven home games is not the heart of this issue here. We're talking about weekend in, weekend out, every day of the week, throughout the year kind of issues.
不。我一点也不买账。那只是你从人们那里听到的猜测，噢，那一定是问题的一部分。他们永远不会去针对校友。事实是，六七场主场比赛发生的事情不是这个问题的核心。我们谈论的是周末、周末，一年中每天都在发生的那些问题。
When this comes up, it's sort of like, well, someone will say, why don't they just make tailgating dry, you know, no alcohol on university property? Is that kind of thing ever even brought up as like a, we just want to signal a culture change? We're just going to make a big bold move and say, we're going to become a different kind of school now? Is that ever on the table?
当这事发生时，这有点像，嗯，有人会说，为什么他们不让汽车后备箱派对禁酒，你知道，大学财产上没酒精？这类事情甚至会被提出作为一种，我们只是想发出文化变革的信号？我们只是要采取一个大胆的举措，说，我们要成为一所不同类型的学校了？这还在议程上吗？
No, I don't think so. I can't envision telling alumni of legal age that they can't drink on a football weekend, and seeing that that's going to change the problem of alcohol consumption among underage students on college campuses. I don't think those two things are really tied together.
不，我不这么认为。我无法想象告诉达到合法年龄的校友他们不能在橄榄球周末喝酒，并认为那会改变大学校园未成年学生酒精消费的问题。我不认为这两件事真的联系在一起。
One bright spot Spanier sees is that there's been a shift at Penn State since he started talking about this 15 years ago. Now for the first time academic deans and faculty leaders and student leaders are wanting to talk about this, saying they want to help.
斯帕尼尔看到的一个亮点是，自从他15年前开始谈论这个问题以来，宾州立大学发生了一些转变。现在第一次，学术院长、教师领袖和学生领袖都想谈论这个，说他们想帮忙。
That is a sea change from what we saw in an earlier era.
那是我们早期所见时代的巨变。
Do you feel optimistic?
你感觉乐观吗？
No. I wouldn't say I feel optimistic. I feel like we just have to keep working on it.
不。我不会说我感觉乐观。我觉得我们只是必须继续努力。
Joe Dado's death, he said, won't have any meaning to next year's freshmen. That's what makes universities like any other enterprise. Every year, the student body turns over by the thousands, so every year, he and his staff have to start all over again.
他说，乔·达多的死亡对明年的新生不会有任何意义。这就是让大学像任何其他企业一样的原因。每年，学生群体成千上万地更替，所以每年，他和他的员工都必须从头开始。
Sarah Koenig.
莎拉·凯尼格。
Here's something else you need to know before we close this hour. People love Penn State. Students were spontaneously telling all of us how much they love the school, how they never want to college experience to end. They chant the school chant, "We are Penn State," not just in the football stadium-- in the student union, shuttle bus, out of the blue. They say "we are Penn State" in conversation, to make a point. They're part of this club that they're really excited to be part of. This feeling gets its purest expression at football games, where they're a hundred thousand strong, screaming together, but it permeates the school.
在结束这个小时之前，还有些事你需要知道。人们爱宾州立大学。学生们自发地告诉我们他们多么爱这所学校，他们多么希望大学经历永不结束。他们高唱学校口号，“我们是宾州立大学”，不仅在橄榄球场——在学生会，穿梭巴士，突如其来。他们说“我们是宾州立大学”在谈话中，为了强调一点。他们是这个俱乐部的一部分，他们真的很高兴成为其中一员。这种感觉在橄榄球比赛中得到了最纯粹的表达，那里有十万人强大，一起尖叫，但它渗透到了学校。
I went to the game when we were there with two juniors, Megan Koch and Zach Fliegel. Megan's Nittany Lions memories include the night of her high school homecoming, which was also the 2005 Michigan game. She was all dressed up. Her dad was on the cell phone.
我们去比赛时带了两个大三学生，梅根·科赫和扎克·弗利格尔。梅根的尼塔尼雄狮记忆包括她高中返校节的那晚，那也是2005年对密歇根的比赛。她盛装打扮。她爸爸在手机上。
He was calling me, telling me, you know, play by play what was going on. And he's like, you're not going to believe this, but Michigan just scored and we lost with two seconds left on the clock. And I remember I just hung up the phone and I was like, oh my gosh. I started like crying.
他给我打电话，告诉我，你知道，比赛进行中的实况。他说，你不会相信的，但密歇根刚得分，我们在离终场两秒时输了。我记得我挂了电话就像，噢我的天。我开始像哭了。
For Zach, it's also about the past and the future. On our way to the stadium, we passed some little boys in the tailgate.
对扎克来说，这关乎过去和未来。在去体育场的路上，我们经过了派对里的一些小男孩。
I used to be that kid, throwing the football around in between cars and stuff.
我过去就是那个孩子，在车之间扔橄榄球。
Lions played, Lions won. It was the last home game of the year, and seniors down in the first row were crying. Zach said even a bad game, being in the stadium, in the student section, was worth it.
雄狮打了，雄狮赢了。那是这一年最后一场主场比赛，坐在第一排的大四学生在哭。扎克说即使比赛很差，在体育场里，在学生区，也是值得的。
I live for this. I'll probably be coming here until I'm old and wrinkled.
我为这个而活。我可能直到老得满脸皱纹都会来这儿。
Really? So like 50 years from now, where will you be sitting? Point to the spot.
真的吗？所以像50年后，你会坐在哪儿？指指那个点。
Hopefully in WC, WD on the 30, 40 yard line, maybe?
希望在30、40码线上的WC、WD，也许？
Show me the seats where you want?
给我看看你想要的座位在哪儿？
And he pointed a third of the way up, 30 yard line. I went around to his friends in the student section. Nobody hesitated. 50 yard line, skybox, 30 yard line. Look for them. 2059. They all want to come back.
他指了指三分之一处，30码线。我去找了他在学生区的朋友。没人犹豫。50码线，包厢，30码线。找他们。2059年。他们都想回来。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and me with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Aaron Scott, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、亚伦·斯科特、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who never could have gotten into the frat party, except that girl insisted.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们的节目由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生监督，他永远也进不去那个兄弟会派对，除了那个女孩坚持。
Look at him! He's so innocent! Look at his face.
看看他！他多天真！看看他的脸。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。